mon grand art président du groupe
écologie solidarité territoire s'oppose
à l'examen selon la procédure de
législation en commission de la
proposition de loi vise dans un
régulariser le pluie de la communauté de
communes du Bas-Chablais inscrite à
l'ordre du jour du mardi 31 janvier acte
est donc donné de cette demande et pour
l'examen du texte nous pourrions prévoir
une discussion générale de 45 minutes
par ailleurs le délai de dépôt des
amendements de séance est fixé ou lundi
30 janvier à 12h y a-t-il des
observations
il en est ainsi décidé l'ordre du jour
appelle la désignation de 19 membres de
la commission d'enquête sur la pénurie
de médicaments et les choix de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et de 21
membres de la mission d'information sur
l'avenir de la commune et du maire en
France en application des articles 8 et
8 ter alinés à 5 notre règlement les
listes des candidats présentées ont été
publiés ces candidatures sont ratifiées
si la présidence ne reçoit pas
d'opposition dans les délais d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle en application
d'article 16 bis alinéa 2 du règlement
la proposition de création d'une
commission spéciale chargée d'examiner
la proposition de loi Visante à facilité
la mise en oeuvre des objectifs de 0
artificiel artificialisation nette au
cœur des territoires je soumet cette
proposition scénario il n'y a pas
d'opposition
je n'en vois pas et donc décidé
conformément à la décision de la
Conférence des Présidents la désignation
des 37 membres de cette commission
spéciale aura lieu en sciences publiques
le mercredi 1er février bien l'ordre du
jour appelle maintenant la discussion du
projet de loi relatif aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 d'un
procédure accélérée a été engagée sur ce
texte et la parole est d'abord à
ministre
madame la Présidente en application de
l'article 44 alinéa 6 du Règlement du
Sénat il y en a encore avec les
commissions des lois des Affaires
sociales et de la culture le
gouvernement souhaite les articles 17 4
et 5 ainsi que l'amendement portant
article additionnels après l'article 4
soit examiné en priorité avant l'article
3 que les articles 9 à 11 et les
amendements portant articles
additionnels s'y rapportant soit examiné
avant l'article 8 et enfin que l'article
18 puisse être examiné avant l'article
bien je voulais que je répète ce que je
viens de dire la ministre donc les
articles 17 4 et 5 et l'amendement
article additionnelle après l'article 4
serait examiné avant l'article 3 les
articles neuf à 11 et les amendements
portantiques additionnels qui leur sont
rattachés sera examinés avant l'article
8 et enfin l'article 18 afin qu'il soit
examinés avant l'article 12 avis de la
commission
favorable favorable pas d'opposition il
y en est donc 1 et la priorité étant
donné dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques madame Boudia Castéra vous
avez la parole
madame la Présidente
Mesdames les rapporteurs monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs l'accueil du monde entier
autour des valeurs de l'Olympie
l'excellence l'amitié le respect des
performances qui ont inspiré les
générations futures pour à leur tour
aller plus vite plus haut plus fort des
infrastructures durablement améliorées
et une première reconnaissance du sport
féminin voilà ce que les jeux de 1924
avaient légué à la France c'était il y a
presque 100 ans chacun le sait en
réinventant les jeux de l'ère moderne
Pierre de Coubertin portait le rêve d'un
événement capable d'influer positivement
sur le cours du monde et ces jeux ont pu
s'affirmer au fil du temps comme
d'exceptionnellement de rapprochement
entre les peuples ils ont toujours été à
l'origine d'exploits sportifs fascinant
d'émotions collectives à nul autre
pareil
pour les pays hautes organisés et
réussir les jeux donc à chaque fois un
honneur conquis de haute lutte une
formidable opportunité mais aussi chacun
le mesure un immense défi aujourd'hui la
France retrouve les Jeux Olympiques pour
la première fois depuis un siècle et
accueille les Jeux paralympiques pour la
première fois de son histoire c'est à
Lausanne sous l'égide du président de la
République il y a 5 ans que le rêve
olympique est paralympique français est
devenu probable et c'est à Lima qu'il
est devenu réalité la délégation
française forge alors cet esprit de Lima
un esprit d'unité qui a permis de poser
les fondations des jeux de paris 2024
esprit que nous ferons vivre depuis le
travail acharné de l'ensemble des
acteurs nous permet d'entamer la
dernière phase de notre préparation avec
confiance c'est sur ce socle que
j'inscris depuis 8 mois mon action à la
tête du ministère des sports et des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques sous
l'autorité de la première ministre et
c'est avec beaucoup de gratitude que je
tiens à remercier ceux qui ont été
pionniers dans cette conquête olympique
collective et je me tourne notamment
vers vous chers Patrick Kanner et je
salue aussi les sénatrices et les
sénateurs qui contribuent à cette
aventure collective et ceux qui plus
largement portent et parfois depuis
longtemps la volonté de voir le sport
mieux inscrit au cœur de notre société à
ce titre je tiens tout particulièrement
à remercier la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication et
son président Laurent Lafont pour votre
vision et pour nos échanges aussi
exigeants que constructifs je le disais
notre équipe est au travail autour du
comité d'organisation et de la solideo
avec Paris la Villotte avec la région
Île-de-France le département de
Seine-Saint-Denis la ville de saint-ny
ainsi que les 70 autres collectivités
hautes impliquées de Lille à Marseille
de Châteauroux à toupo
et bien sûr autour de l'ensemble des
ministères concernés tous mobilisés et
coordonnés par la Délégation
interministérielle aux Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques dirigés par le préfet
Michel Cadot le pilotage de ce projet
nous devons le rendre toujours plus
efficace comme nous y appelle à juste
titre le rapport récent de la Cour des
comptes pour être à la hauteur de cet
événement d'une immense envergure
notamment en termes sportif avec 15000
athlètes engagés médiatique avec plus de
4 milliards de téléspectateurs et aussi
organisationnels avec l'équivalent de 43
championnats du monde à organiser en
simultanée 800 mille personnes à
acheminer chaque jour et le déploiement
quotidien d'environ 50 000 forces de
sécurité publique et privés
j'ai l'habitude de dire que réussir les
jeux c'est réunir un quatuor d'exigence
d'abord l'organisation la plus
irréprochable possible ensuite des
athlètes aux meilleurs de leur
performances aussi des jeux qui soit une
vraie fête populaire pour tous les
Français et à travers tous les
territoires et enfin des jeux qui
laissent un héritage durable
utile au pays notamment
Seine-Saint-Denis qui concentre plus de
80% des investissements publics du
projet mais aussi en faisant de notre
pays une nation sportive raison pour
laquelle le président de la République a
d'ores est déjà choisi de faire en 2024
de l'activité physique et sportive la
grande cause nationale
cet événement doit aussi refléter ce que
nous savons être et faire de meilleur à
travers plusieurs grands marqueurs la
parité puisque pour la première fois à
Paris seront engagés dans les épreuves
olympiques un nombre exactement
équivalent d'athlètes femmes et hommes
la compacité avec 95% d'équipement
éphémères ou déjà existants pour en
finir avec le phénomène des éléphants
blancs qui ont encore certaines rues
d'Athènes et de Rio l'exemplarité
écologique avec notamment une division
par deux des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par rapport aux éditions
précédentes la maîtrise des budgets en
dépit du contexte d'inflation que chacun
connaît conditions clés de
l'acceptabilité sociale de ces jeux
l'exigence sociale avec 25% des marchés
réservés au TPE et un objectif de 2
millions d'heures d'insertion au
bénéfice des publics les plus éloignés
de l'emploi ces jeux vont être en fin
les plus grands jeux paralympiques de
l'histoire et à ce titre constitue une
opportunité tout à fait unique de
changer le regard porté par notre
société sur le handicap pour nous
permettre de finaliser ces jeux leur
préparation avec l'exigence la précision
et la fiabilité que vous attendez de
nous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
votre travail de législateur est un
soubassement et même parfois un
préalable indispensable c'est dans cet
esprit que vous aviez déjà adopté la loi
olympique du 26 mars 2018 pour traduire
les engagements de la candidature
française du CIO et du Contrat de Ville
Haute aujourd'hui à 549 jours d'une
cérémonie d'ouverture inédite sur la
scène nous sommes face à un compte à
rebours implacable et nous avons
identifié avec l'ensemble des ministères
et partenaires concernés les ajustements
incontournables qu'il nous reste à
adopter pour aller au bout de nos
engagements et de nos besoins
opérationnels pour la livraison et le le
déroulement des jeux c'est tout l'objet
de ce projet de loi que j'ai aujourd'hui
l'honneur de porter devant vous
permettez-moi d'en exposer les
principaux objectifs d'abord soigner et
porter secours il nous revient ainsi de
créer le temps des jeux un centre de
santé au sein du Village olympique et
paralympique pour les athlètes et les
populations accrédités centre de santé
qui sera géré dans un cadre simplifié
par l'APHP sous le contrôle de l'agence
régionale de santé d'Île-de-France et
qui évitera de peser sur les capacités
de notre système de santé dans le cadre
d'une dérogation temporaire nous allons
autoriser à exercer dans cette
polyclinique en France les médecins
étrangers accompagnant les fédérations
internationales et les délégations
olympiques nous allons aussi étendre la
liste des organismes habilités à former
au premier secours au delà des
associations agréées de sécurité civile
deuxième objectif promouvoir un sport
sans dopage par ce texte nous entendons
maintenir la France à l'avant-garde de
la lutte contre le dopage ou en leur
temps mais prédécesseurs Marie-Georges
Buffet Jean-François Lamour Valérie
Fourneyron ont su la placer il nous faut
rester à ce niveau d'excellence et
continuer de répondre à nos obligations
internationales en la matière édictée
par l'Agence mondiale antidopage et
découlant de la Convention de l'UNESCO
ratifié par le Parlement pour cela il
nous faut non seulement étendre à la
Polynésie française ou se dérouleront
les épreuves de surf les disposition
essentielles de la lutte contre le
dopage en matière pénale mais aussi
ouvrir la possibilité de réaliser des
analyses génétiques comme cela a été
fait à Pékin et à Tokyo pour déceler les
fraudes qui ne peuvent l'être d'aucune
autre façon et ainsi éviter qu'une
faille un point de fuite dans notre
édifice ne vienne en la crédibilité tout
entière j'ai entendu vos inquiétudes sur
ce sujet génétique et nous en avons pris
la mesure en l'entourant de toutes les
garanties nécessaires informations
Express des personnes concernées
usage en tout dernier recours seulement
pour des situations et des finalités
limitativement énumérées au moyen
deschantillons anonymisés et promptement
détruit ne permettant ni
identification ni sélection ni profilage
des sportifs concernés nous avons ainsi
veillé à concilier au mieux les
impératifs de l'éthique et de
l'intégrité sportive dans le respect de
nos obligations internationales
troisième objectif protéger toutes les
populations avec Gérald Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
nous sommes parfaitement lucides sur le
fait que la réussite des jeux est
d'abord conditionnée à l'intérieur
nécessité d'en sécuriser chaque
dimension les enceintes sportive les
quatre cérémonies d'ouverture et de
clôture le relais de la flamme et d'agir
sur la préservation de l'ordre public la
prévention de la délinquance aux abords
de tous nos sites la cybersécurité ou
encore la gestion efficace des flux de
personnes de l'arrivée sur notre
territoire jusqu'à nos métros nos bus et
nos RER par ce projet de loi nous
souhaitons donc disposer de moyens
renforcés pour détecter plus rapidement
et plus facilement par la
vidéoprotection les risques graves tels
que les mouvements de foule les colis
suspects les goulets d'étranglement dans
les transports nous souhaitons aussi
améliorer et fluidifier le contrôle à
l'entrée des sites de compétition et de
célébration mieux coordonnées les
équipes mobilisées pour la sécurité dans
les transports enfin assurer une unité
de commandement des forces de sécurité
pendant la période des jeux
là aussi nous avons entendu les
questions sur la nature de certains
dispositifs comme le traitement par
algorithme des images de la
vidéoprotection qui continuent je le
sais d'interroger sur certains bancs de
cette émission mais nous voulons
souligner que les très nombreuses
garanties mises en place dans le cadre
de cette expérimentation nous aiderons à
être au rendez-vous de la sécurité des
jeux tout en préservant les droits et
libertés de nos concitoyens en parfaite
conformité avec le droit européen de la
protection des données dans ce cadre
nous avons en effet suivi à la lettre
les recommandations de la CNIL et
définit une ligne claire nous ne voulons
pas de la reconnaissance faciale pour
les jeux non seulement celle-ci ne nous
paraît pas opérationnellement nécessaire
mais surtout les autres dispositifs
prévus dans ce chapitre sur la sécurité
permettront déjà un saut qualitatif dans
la prévention et la lutte contre les
troubles possibles à l'ordre public
enfin sur ce volet de la sécurité nous
voulons tirer tous les enseignements des
événements survenus lors du Stade de
France le 28 mai dernier puis le
lendemain au stade Geoffroy-Guichard je
salue à cet égard le travail réalisé par
les deux commissions du Sénat qui
avaient analysé ces incidents qui
avaient recommandé un ensemble
d'améliorations dont nous avons tenu
compte dans ce projet ainsi nous
souhaitons renforcer les sanctions
individuelles prononcées par le juge
judiciaire en cas d'entrée par force ou
par fraude dans les enceintes ou en cas
d'intrusion sans motif légitime sur
l'air de compétition de même il vous est
proposé de rendre systématique les
interdictions judiciaires de stade pour
les infractions pénales les plus graves
par exemple l'introduction d'objets
susceptible de constituer une arme les
jets de projectiles ou encore la
provocation à la haine à la violence ou
l'incitation à la discrimination
vous savez ma détermination à lutter
contre ces débordements détestables dans
nos stades une détermination je le sais
que vous partagez pour garantir en
héritage des jeux un sport et des stades
dans lesquels la violence n'a plus sa
place
quatrième objectif favoriser
l'accessibilité dans les transports avec
le ministre Clément bonne nous avons
évalué que pour être au rendez-vous de
cette exigence d'accessibilité dans les
transports franciliens il était
nécessaire de passer de moins de 250
taxis adaptés aux personnes à mobilité
réduite aujourd'hui à plus de 1000 pour
les jeux pour cela nous souhaitons à
titre expérimental permettre au préfet
de police de délivrer de nouvelles
licences de taxi PMR dans des conditions
simplifiées cinquième objectif favoriser
le potentiel économique dans les
territoires ce projet de loi doit
d'abord nous permettre de respecter les
engagements du contrat de vie l'autre en
matière publicitaire vis-à-vis des
partenaires des jeux lors du relais de
la flamme et du compte à rebours tout en
les conciliant avec l'exigence de
protection de l'environnement l'activité
commerçante doit aussi être en mesure de
répondre à l'afflux de touristes de
spectateurs et de travailleurs à cette
fin il vous proposer de permettre aux
préfets d'autoriser entre le 1er juin et
le 30 septembre 2024 le commerce
dominical sous réserve d'un accord des
salariés de contrepartie légale et après
consultation des élus locaux ainsi que
des chambres consulaires 6e et dernier
objectif conservez nos talents jusqu'aux
jeux il nous a paru indispensable de
permettre aux équipes engagées depuis de
nombreuses années dans cette aventure
des jeux d'être mobilisés jusqu'au bout
en prévoyant deux mesures relatives
l'une à la limite d'âge l'autre à
l'avenir de la solideo appelé à se
rapprocher de grands Paris aménagements
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs l'essentiel des mesures que
nous vous proposons nous avons veillé à
définir de manière claire et
transparente celle de ces mesures qui
sont limitées au temps des jeux ou
expérimental environ la moitié et celle
l'autre moitié qui ont vocation à
s'inscrire de façon pérenne dans
l'héritage de l'événement et à
bénéficier à d'autres manifestations
culturel ou festive après les Jeux
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs au
regard des échanges que nous avons eu
tout au long de ces dernières semaines
et de l'esprit qui préside
traditionnellement aux travaux de la
Chambre haute j'ai confiance dans le
fait que vous partagerez notre vision
d'un texte équilibré
utile centré sur l'essentiel protecteur
des trois et libertés sans passer à côté
des exigences d'innovation et de
modernisation auxquelles nous sommes
ponctuellement appelés mais dernier mot
sont enfin pour remercier Madame la
rapporteur canaillé madame la rapporteur
la Sarrade monsieur le rapporteur Kern
pour la qualité de vos analyses de nos
échanges et de vos propositions sur ce
texte et pour saluer les apports des
travaux en commission que je vous
laisserai exposer en particulier
l'amélioration du cadre envisagé pour
les analyses génétiques antidopage le
déploiement d'une billetterie nominative
dématérialisée et infalsifiable pour
certaines compétitions sportives et
l'ajustement le plus proportionné
possible à la gravité des faits mesure
de lutte contre les violences dans les
stades tout au long de nos débats je
serai à votre écoute avec la volonté
d'améliorer là où c'est encore
nécessaire ce projet de loi mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est la France
qui à la fin du 19e siècle a redonné
naissance au jeu c'est elle qui avec
Alice milliard à inventé les jeux
féminins mais aussi les jeux diffèrent
ou encore le village des athlètes c'est
donc dans la fidélité à cet esprit
d'innovation que les jeux de paris 2024
vont dessiner une nouvelle référence
olympique ils seront une opportunité
unique et réussie de faire rayonner la
France une France ouverte sur le monde
audacieuse et responsable assumant ses
idéaux universelles mais aussi son amour
pour le sport je vous remercie
madame leur rapportant de la commission
des lois madame canailler vous avez la
parole pour 10 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers collègues dans un 148
jours les Jeux Olympiques et paroles
olympiques 2024 ouvriront à Paris 100
ans après les Jeux de 1924 désolé sont
plus qu'un simple rendez-vous sportif sa
maman de cohésion nationale de
fraternité humaine c'est également une
vitrine pour l'autre qui expose aux yeux
du monde de savoir-faire français et une
certaine façon de célébrer l'esprit
olympique le mérite la maîtrise de soi
le dépassement sera ce sera surtout un
événement d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
du point de vue sportif tout d'abord
avec 10500 athlètes de 32 disciplines
différentes qui se mesureront lors de
549 épreuves du point de vue
organisationnel pardon puisque les
compétitions se dérouleront dans 37
sites olympiques y compris en Polynésie
pour le surf une mobiliseront 63
collectivités et plus de 40000 bénévoles
enfin du point de vue événementiel cette
fête réunira 13,5 millions de
spectateurs 20000 journalistes
accrédités et 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs dans le monde entier
fait inédit la cérémonie d'ouverture des
Jeux se fera le long de la Seine sur 6
km du Pont d'Austerlitz jusqu'à celui
d'Iéna où se dérouleront les spectacles
et les cérémonies protocolaires c'est la
première fois qu'un tel événement se
réalise en dehors d'un stade fermé cette
innovation qui devrait réunir 600 000
spectateurs est aussi un défi pour la
sécurité cette grande fête populaire est
sportif au réalisera la tension du monde
entier elle impose une organisation
exemplaire pour être au rendez-vous
livrez les équipements dans les temps
faire monter la puissance en puissance
les capacités de transport coordonner
les différents acteurs et prévoir une
organisation de la sécurité aller à la
hauteur de l'événement sont autant défi
qui seront à révélé révéler d'ici juin
2024 et évidemment préparer des athlètes
afin de récolter un maximum de médailles
afin de favoriser la préparation de
l'événement une première loi relative
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques a
été adopté le 26 mars 2018 comme le
souligne la Cour des comptes dans son
rapport enduit il y a quelques jours la
phase de planification stratégique des
jeux c'est globalement bien déroulé il
convient donc désormais de passer de la
phase de planification à la phase de
déclinaison opérationnelle c'est tout
l'objet de ce nouveau projet de loi
soumis à notre examen ce texte intitulé
sobrement Jeux Olympiques et para
olympiques de 2024 regroupe diverses
mesures d'ampleur inégales et qui pour
l'essentiel ne concerne pas uniquement
l'organisation des JO mais ont une
portée plus étendue sur 19 articles
proposées seul 8 sont spécifiquement
ciblés sur les jeux de 2024 comme par
exemple l'installation d'un centre de
santé
l'extension des prérogatives du préfet
de police de Paris la dérogation à
l'interdiction de publicité sur le
parcours de la
des commerces le dimanche ou le devenir
de la solideo huit mesures portent sur
des mises en conformité avec des
dispositions existantes ou la création
de nouveaux dispositifs pérennes et deux
articles instaure des expérimentations
dont les JO sont un accélérateur et qui
ont vocation a perduré l'un sur la
vidéoprotection intelligente et l'autre
sur l'augmentation du nombre de taxis
accessibles aux personnes à mobilité
réduite si l'ensemble de ces
dispositions souvent techniques sont
nécessaires à la bonne réussite des Jeux
Olympiques deux dispositifs nouveaux
soulèvent lesineuses questions du juste
équilibre entre la recherche
d'efficacité et la garantie des droits
et libertés individuelles que ce soit en
matière de lutte contre le dopage ou de
sécurisation des jeux la France est
engagée avec force depuis les années 90
dans la lutte contre le dopage essentiel
pour assurer l'équité entre les sportifs
et garantir leur santé
afin d'obtenir l'organisation des Jeux
en 2024 la France a promis de compléter
son arsenal de mesure antidopage par
l'introduction des tests génétiques
conformément à ces engagements
internationaux pris en 2007
paradoxalement alors que l'introduction
du recours au test génétique assure la
mise en conformité du droit français
avec le code mondial antidopage
l'article 4 initial du projet de loi ne
prévoyait de s'appliquer jusqu'au 31
décembre 2024 comment accepter que les
sportifs français ne puissent être
soumis au test génétique en France alors
qu'ils y sont soumis partout ailleurs en
effet ces tests sont aujourd'hui les
seuls à permettre de confirmer la
manipulation d'échantillons d'écarter
une suspicion de transfusion de sang
homologues de vérifier l'inexistence
d'une mutation génétique rare qui
conduit un taux de PO supérieur à la
moyenne ou de détecter les manipulations
génétiques qui permettent d'augmenter la
performance c'est pourquoi la des lois
adopter un amendement réécrivant
l'article 4 afin d'inscrire dans le code
des sports la possibilité de recourir au
test génétique pour les deux premières
finalités
notamment sur le caractère subsidiaire
des tests nous avons assorti des
garanties sur l'anonymat des
échantillons sur l'interdiction de
connaître le patrimoine génétique en
entier ou sur le fait de recourir à
l'identification ou à le profilage du
sportif
pour la vérification des manipulations
génétiques qui font appel à l'ADN plus
codant la Commission avait introduit le
recours à l'expérimentation depuis nous
avons poursuivi nos échanges notamment
avec l'AFLD Elita qui nous ont affirmé
que cette répartition posait des
difficultés techniques et n’assortissez
pas l'ensemble des tests des mêmes
garanties c'est pourquoi je vous
proposerai de pérenniser l'ensemble de
ces tests tout en renforçant les
garanties afférentes l'adoption des
règles de lutte antidopage en Polynésie
fait objet de l'article 5 dans les
dispositions ont été enrichis par nos
discussions chères Lana avec la
collectivité de Polynésie mais surtout
l'ampleur de l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques imposent de
se doter d'une organisation
irréprochable en matière de sécurité
d'autant que la menace terroriste est
toujours élevée en France à cela
s'ajoute de risques majeurs le risque
cyber et le risque sanitaire et la
sécurisation de la cérémonie d'ouverture
en plein air complexifie la tâche
les premières estimations indiquent que
les jeux nécessitent la mobilisation de
moyens quotidiens humains et matériels
conséquent de 22000 à 33000 agents de
sécurité privée dont le recrutement pose
d'ailleurs quelques difficultés 45000
agents publics force de sécurité
intérieure et armées
l'acceptabilité des jeux implique en
nous un équilibre soit trouvé entre les
missions de sécurité liées au jeu et la
permanence des autres mesures sur le
reste du territoire l'utilisation des
images prise par des caméras de
vidéoprotection ou les drones doit être
informé en renforcé pour aider les
forces de l'ordre à sécuriser les
espaces publics trois articles y
concours la mise en conformité prévue à
l'article 6 des types positions
relatives à la vidéoprotection avec le
rgpd renforce les garanties liées au
traitement personnel comme nous la
souhaiter la CNIL l'expérimentation de
l'utilisation de la vidéoprotection
intelligente ou caméra augmentée
inscrite à l'article 7 est une
innovation majeure mais elle soulève de
nombreuses questions en matière de
liberté publique à mettre en balance
avec les avancées opérationnelles d'un
tel dispositif notamment pour les JO
le traitement par des algorithmes des
images captées permettra de détecter
signaler des événements prédéterminés
susceptibles de menacer la sécurité des
personnes elle sera un outil d'aide à la
décision pour les forces de sécurité qui
pourront se concentrer sur l'action
cette innovation est d'ailleurs une des
recommandations du rapport de nos
collègues Marc philippe daubrais Arnaud
delnay et Jérôme Durin dans le rapport
sur la reconnaissance biométrique
adoptée par la commission des lois le 10
mai dernier réécrit après les avis du
Conseil d'État et de la CNIL l'article 7
instaure de nombreuses garanties tout au
long des étapes de mise en œuvre de ce
dispositif la commission des Lois du
Sénat a considéré c'est garanties assuré
un équilibre satisfaisant entre
protection des droits et libertés et la
plus grande opérationnalité en matière
de sécurité elle a d'ailleurs souhaité
sécurisé cette procédure en renforçant
le contrôle de la CNIL tant dans la mise
en oeuvre du traitement que dans le
suivi et l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation
enfin le criblage des fanzones et de
tous les participants ainsi que le
recours au scanner corporel à onde
millimétrique pour les gestionnaires
d'enceintes sportives qui le souhaitent
assurant eux aussi une meilleure
sécurisation des grands événements
accueillis par la France mes chers
collègues les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques sont tous les quatre ans
des événements sportifs singuliers qui
justifient la mobilisation de moyens
exceptionnels pour en conserver le
caractère fictif il faut que nous soyons
prêts il faut que la France soit prête
les mesures contenues dans ce projet de
loi enrichi par le Sénat permettent de
donner des outils supplémentaires pour
que la France réussisse cette épreuve
unique et hors norme au hors normes le
Sénat sera bien évidemment au
rendez-vous de l'application du respect
de la loi dans son esprit je vous
remercie
la parole est maintenant Madame Florence
lassarade rapporteur pour ravi de la
commission des affaires sociales et pour
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales s'est vue déléguer
l'examen des dispositions du texte ils
ont concernent la santé et le travail
l'article premier prévoit la création de
la polyclinique olympique et
paralympique sous la forme d'un centre
de santé au statut aménagé la structure
qui sera gérée par l'Assistance publique
hôpitaux de Paris visa mettre à
disposition des seules athlètes et
personnes accrédité une offre de soins
de premier recours outre un encadrement
composé de salariés de la PHP le
fonctionnement du centre reposera sur
des praticiens volontaires olympiques et
paralympique au pic d'activité ceci
devrait être 193 dans 36 médecins 28
masseurs kinésithérapeute et 14
infirmiers trois principales dérogations
ont été identifiés comme nécessaire au
fonctionnement de ce centre de santé il
s'agit notamment de clarifier le public
spécifique restreint auquel la
polyclinique s'adresse mais aussi
prévoir la gratuité de ces prestations
ou encore la présence d'une pharmacie
hos journalière le même article premier
simplifie également différentes
procédures relatives au projet de santé
ou encore à l'installation d'équipements
d'imagerie la commission des affaires
sociales à soutenu le dispositif proposé
et à veiller à préciser le statut
dérogatoire de la politique
l'article 2 complète l'article premier
sur l'organisation d'une offre de soins
spécifiques au jeu en autorisant
l'exercice de leur profession à trois
grandes catégories de professionnelles
de santé mobilisées par l'événement mais
qui ne justifierait pas des reconditions
requises pour exercer leur profession en
France il s'agit d'abord des médecins
des fédérations à crédités autorisées à
exercer sur les seules athlètes
concernées il s'agit ensuite des
professionnels de santé accompagnant les
délégations de sportifs lesquels ne
pourraient exercer qu'à l'égard du
personnel et des membres de la
délégation qui l'accompagne enfin
l'article 2 autorise l'exercice de leur
professionnelle de santé étrangers qui
pourraient participer à l'activité de la
polyclinique en tant que volontaire
selon une procédure qui reste toutefois
à établir avec l'ordre des médecins
la commission des affaires sociales a
approuvé ses dispositions elle a
également approuvé la création à
l'article 17 d'une dérogation au repos
dominicale pour les commerces de détails
qui seront situés dans les communes où
auront lieu les compétitions ainsi que
dans les communes limitrophes et à
proximité les très nombreux visiteurs
attendus pendant les jeux doivent être
accueillis dans le meilleur conditions
et les besoins du public sont seront
sources de développement économique
cette mesure est assortie de garantie
pour les salariés seuls les salariés
volontaires travailleront le dimanche et
il bénéficieront d'une rémunération
doublée et de repos condensateurs elle
s'ajoutera aux dérogation déjà
existantes comme les dimanches du maire
ou les ouvertures en zone touristiques
pour s'adapter aux besoins exceptionnels
liés aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
compte tenu des nombreuses demandes de
dérogation attendues des besoins du
public déjà prévisibles et du caractère
bien circonscrit de la mesure notre
commission à simplifier la procédure
d'autorisation préfectorale afin que le
préfet puisse d'emblée autoriser un ou
plusieurs établissements à déroger au
repos dominical au lieu de procéder par
autorisation individuelle puis par
arrêter d'extension
un mot enfin sur l'article 4 sur lequel
la commission des affaires sociales
s'est saisie pour agi cet article
complète l'arsenal de la lutte
antidopage on autorisant l'examen des
caractéristiques génétiques pour
rechercher quatre méthodes possibles
d'amélioration des performances et en
prévoyant l'orientation du sportif vers
une consultation adaptée lorsqu’un tel
examen provoque la découverte incidente
d'une caractéristique responsable d'une
possible infection
cet article est donc utile pour adapter
la lutte antidopage à l'innovation en
matière de triche il nous est surtout
imposé par les règles mondiales
antidopage la commission des affaires
sociales est donc favorable à l'adoption
des articles dans la rédaction issue de
ce travaux je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Claude
Kern rapporteur pour un vide la
commission de la culture d'éducation et
de la communication
et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues comme cela a été rappelé
ce projet de loi relatif aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 constitue probablement la dernière
occasion d'adapter notre droit aux
nécessitait apparu pour assurer la bonne
tenue de cet événement il représente
également la première opportunité pour
tirer les conséquences des événements
survenus au Stade de France le 28 mai
2022 qui ont vu de très nombreux
délinquants forcer l'entrée du stade et
plusieurs milliers de fraudeurs tentés
de s'introduire avec des billets
falsifiés
ces événements qui ont gravement entaché
la réputation de notre pays à organiser
de grandes manifestations
s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'une
recrudescence des violences dans les
stades d'une part et du développement
des vols avec violence dans la capitale
d'autres parts au moment où plusieurs
centaines de milliers de spectateurs
s'apprêtent à nous rendre visite en 2023
et 2024 pour assister à ses compétitions
la commission de la culture qui s'est vu
déléguer au fond l'examen des articles
12 13 et 14 a souhaité tirer toutes les
conséquences de ces événements en
modifiant le texte dans deux directions
tout d'abord en faisant suite à la
recommandation numéro 1 du rapport des
présidents buffets Lafont du 13 juillet
dernier qui proposait de rendre
obligatoire le recours à une billetterie
infalsifiable pour les grands événements
sportifs et je remercie madame la
ministre des Sports pour son écoute sur
ce sujet la rédaction que le Sénat
examine aujourd'hui porte la marque de
nos échanges
en complétant ensuite l'arsenal
juridique afin de sanctionner plus
sévèrement les primo délinquants isolés
qui tentent de s'introduire dans les
antains enceintes sportives ou sur les
aires de compétition notre commission a
créé à cet égard une nouvelle amende
délictuelle afin de renforcer l'effet
dyslasif de ces dispositions tout en
respectant le principe de
proportionnalité des peines notre
commission a donné un avis défavorable à
plusieurs amendements qui visent soit à
réduire les peines contre les
délinquants qui cherchent à rentrer de
force dans les stades soit à ne pas
condamner les activistes qui
interrompent les retransmissions
sportives pour imposer leurs messages
politiques soit à rendre inopérant le
dispositif des interdictions de stade je
suis donc obligé de constater que la
nécessité de lutter contre les violences
de toute nature qui prolifèrent dans nos
stades ne fait pas consensus
je le regrette d'autant plus que nous
connaissons ces derniers mois une
augmentation des violences dans le sport
au sens large et qu'il ne me semble pas
envisageable de baisser la garde à
quelques mois du début des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques je
terminerai en rappelant la nécessité
pour chacun d'entre nous de conclure du
mieux possible au succès de ces jeux de
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
pardon pour le Parlement cela signifie
au moins deux choses
tout d'abord mener à bien le débat de ce
texte afin de clarifier le droit
applicable et je salue madame la
ministre votre écoute par rapport à nos
interrogations et les réponses que vous
avez apportées à nos propositions
en second lieu il nous revient de
veiller aux équilibres budgétaires de
cet événement et c'est le sens de notre
amendement qui demande à la Cour des
comptes de rendre au Parlement
un rapport d'étape faisant le bilan des
jeux avant le premier octobre 2025
nos échanges avec la Cour ont permis
d'établir le caractère indispensable de
ce rendez-vous qui bien entendu n'obéira
en rien les travaux que celle-ci mènera
d'ici 2026 pour réaliser un bilan
financier définitif de cet événement
mais il me semble essentiel que les
Français sachent que leurs élus veillent
au respect du budget des jeux compte
tenu de la garantie financière apportée
par l'État j'en profite pour remercier
la rapporteur Agnès canaillé et
monomologue rapporteur pour avis
Florence lasarade pour l'excellente
collaboration et les échanges fructueux
je vous remercie
merci nous allons maintenant passer à la
discussion de la motion tendance à
opposé l'exceptionabilité
cette exception diraçabilité a été
déposée par Madame Eliane Assassin's
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste et la parole est donc à
madame la Présidente pour cette motion
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la Charte olympique
prévoit que le but de l'olympisme est de
mettre le sport au service du
développement harmonieux de l'humanité
en vue de promouvoir une société
Pacifique soucieuse de préserver la
dignité humaine dans notre monde
globalisé le sport à ce pouvoir unique
de rassembler les peuples et le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologique ne peut que souscrire à
l'esprit des Jeux Olympiques mes chers
collègues mon groupe émettra des
critiques mais en aucun cas nous ne
dévaluons l'importance du sport qui est
l'un des quelques domaines de l'activité
humaine qui est universelle des règles
universelles mais également des valeurs
universelles l'encadre celle du
fair-play du respect de l'amitié qui
sont reconnus dans le monde entier le
groupe CRCE reconnaît et soutient le
pouvoir rassembleur et d'intégration du
sport néanmoins nous ne pouvons que
regretter et dénoncer un texte hautement
sécuritaire qui porte mal son nom il est
bien dommage que ce texte nous parle
moins de sport que de sécurité mon
groupe considère que la devise olympique
plus plus vite plus haut plus fort est
ici détourné pour un plus vite plus haut
plus fort de sécurité et d'atteinte au
droit à la vie privée protégée par
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 et la
liberté d'aller venir telle que protégée
par l'article 2 et 4 de cette même
déclaration
ce projet de loi j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de dire est un cheval de Troie tant les
dispositions attentatoires aux libertés
et droits fondamentaux qu'il comporte
seront susceptibles d'être pérennes et
c'est déjà le cas pour 11 d'entre elles
ainsi nous dénonçons un projet de loi
porteur de graves atteintes à des
libertés constitutionnellement garanties
et mon groupe se doit de tirer la
sonnette d'alarme nous ne laisserons pas
passer de telles atteintes qui gâcheront
la fête nous sommes bien malheureux de
constater que le Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 seront un
accélérateur de surveillance certes nous
ne pouvons nier l'enjeu de la sécurité
oui les jeux 2024 nécessitent
organisation et sécurité à un niveau
exceptionnel à titre d'exemple la
Seine-Saint-Denis va accueillir le
village olympique en 2024 en tant que
sénatrice de ce département je
m'inquiète le fiasco de l'organisation
de la finale de la Ligue des Champions
en mai 2022 a mis en lumière les
carences de la France a assuré la
sécurité d'un événement sportif majeur
et pourtant pourtant face à cet enjeu
qui semble si important à vos yeux vous
nous proposez de recourir à des
entreprises privées nous dénonçons votre
réponse qui n'est pas à la hauteur de
l'ambition nécessaire car oui mes chers
collègues le recours au 22000 à 33000
agents de sécurité privée demandée par
le comité d'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pour
encadrer les JO 2024 confirme la
tendance grâce à l'intégration de la
sécurité privée en tant que force de
police institutionnalisée et bras armés
de l'État encore une fois et tout comme
nous l'avions dénoncé dénoncé lors de la
locmi la sécurité privée ne doit pas
être confondue avec la sécurité étatique
au risque de se solder par un cuisant
échec telle qu'essuyé par les JO de
Londres en 2012 nous ne pouvons que
rappeler que cette montée en puissance
dissimule également la marchandisation
de la sécurité publique et la délégation
des missions de service public à des
entreprises qui n'ont pour unique
finalité que la recherche de la rente
une finalité bien éloignée des fonctions
régaliennes de l'État il y a ici un
manque de cohérence en matière de
politique publique que l'on avait déjà
pointé du doigt à l'occasion de la
sécurité globale de mai 2021 mais
également lors de la l'examen de la
lokhnie aussi nous tenons à dénoncer que
la gestion sécuritaire des JO se traduit
également par les opérations
antidélinquance menées depuis novembre
2022 et qui continueront jusqu'au jeu
aujourd'hui deux opérations
antidélinquance d'envergure sont menées
chaque jour à Paris en Seine-Saint-Denis
deux par semaine dans les Hauts-de-Seine
et le Val-de-Marne sans compter les
initiatives de moins de ampleur plus
quotidienne entre le 7 et le 27 novembre
235 de ces opérations ont été conduites
pour une cinquantaine de garde à vue
était-ce bien nécessaire est-ce bien
nécessaire la locmin nous l'annonçait
déjà les JO seront l'occasion de la
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
répressive et sécuritaire du ministère
de l'Intérieur une doctrine à laquelle
mon groupe s'oppose fermement et à
laquelle je le redis encore une fois
nous préférons le triptyque prévention
dissuasion répression de plus mon groupe
s'oppose fermement à la légalisation de
la vidéo surveillance algorithmique
portée par ce projet de loi la détection
par logiciel d'événements et de
comportement dit suspect portera une
nouvelle fois une atteinte
disproportionnée au droit à la vie
privée à la liberté d'aller et venir des
participants une légalisation qui sera
une occasion pour les entreprises
françaises de montrer leur savoir-faire
en matière de répression et pour le
gouvernement de déployer une technologie
encore illégale mais dont les offres
commerciales sont déjà très présentes
nous dénonçons des jeux qui sont une
étape pour travailler l'acceptation par
la population de telles technologies et
oui l'état d'exception créé par les JO
permet de faire passer des lois
sécuritaires qui resteront par la suite
ne nous l'aurons pas sur un autre aspect
tout aussi important alors que
l'Assemblée nationale va débuter
l'examen de la réforme des retraites le
projet de loi prévoit un recul
scandaleux de la limite d'âge des
fonctionnaires occupants des emplois
participants directement à
l'organisation des Jeux au nom de
l'intérêt du service et ce jusqu'au 31
décembre 2024 dans la même veine
l'ouverture des commerces de vente les
dimanches dans les communes décident de
compétition et à proximité remets en
cause le principe du repos dominical et
porte atteinte au droit fondamental à la
vie privée familiale par ailleurs le
projet de loi comporte un seul aspect
concrètement en lien avec le sport à
savoir le contrôle anti-dopage et je
vous remercie madame la ministre d'avoir
cité parmi les ministres des sports mon
ami Marie-Georges Buffet qui a beaucoup
travaillé sur le sujet le texte envisage
donc d'autoriser le temps des jeux
l'examen des caractéristiques génétiques
d'une personne ou son identification par
ses empreintes génétiques afin de mieux
réaliser un contrôle antidopathe dopage
si cette transposition d'une norme
internationale encadrant le contrôle
antidopage est nécessaire au déroulement
des JO mais aussi de la Coupe du monde
de rugby l'acnil et la Ligue des droits
de l'Homme dénonce du site des tests
particulièrement intrusifs qui dérochent
de façon importante au principe
encadrant actuellement les analyses
génétiques dans le Code civil là aussi
mon groupe dénonce ce paradoxalement
temporaire de cette mesure qui sera en
définitive appelée à se pérenniser et ce
à leur même que celle-ci Déroche de
manière disproportionnée à des
dispositions du Code civil enfin si la
tenue des Jeux Olympiques est
paralympique pouvaient représenter une
forme opportunité de modernisation et
d'amélioration de la qualité du service
du réseau francilien il se pose
aujourd'hui la question de la capacité
d'Île-de-France mobilité à répondre aux
défis de saturation alors que de
nouvelles lignes de métro auraient dû
être prêtes pour relier les différents
sites des JO et permettent le transport
de 10 millions de personnes seul le
prolongement de la ligne 14 sera livrée
à temps les promesses de réponds aux
besoins de mobilité générée par les jeux
et ceux de manière décarbonée auront du
mal à être tenu et ce n'est pas une
privatisation voulue par certains qui
amélioraient améliorerait pardon la
situation toujours au sujet des
transports nous considérons que
l'extension des images une vidéo
protection auxquelles ont accès les
agents de service interne de la SNCF et
de la RATP ne possèdent pas une
considération équilibrée entre
l'objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
de prévention des atteintes à l'ordre
public quelle poursuit et le droit au
respect de la vie privée des usagers
pour conclure mon groupe considère que
ce projet de loi libéral et sécurité ne
respecte pas le juste équilibre entre
sécurité et protection des libertés et
droits fondamentaux il n'honore pas les
Jeux Olympiques et portent de graves
atteintes aux libertés publiques en ce
sens nous considérons qu'il est
contraire au bloc de constitutionnalité
si vous le permettez j'aurai un dernier
mot pour celles et ceux qui sont exclus
face au prix des billets exorbitants et
ne verront les Jeux Olympiques que de
loin tout compte fait et je dois dire
que cela est bien dommage les JO 2024
qui devraient être une énorme fête
populaire seront un mirage de
convivialité je vous appelle ainsi
notre notion d'y recevabilité qui vous
la décompris se justifie en pleinement
je vous remercie merci
pour répondre
à cette motion de procédure la parole
est maintenant à Madame Nathalie Bellay
mes collègues communistes souhaitent que
l'examen de ce texte s'achève avant même
qu'il ne débute réellement jugeant qu'un
certain nombre de ces dispositions sont
attentatoires liberté publique ce n'est
pas notre position d'abord la tenue des
Jeux Olympiques est imminente et des
délais supplémentaires ne feraient que
compliquer voire même me rendre
impossible la tâche des organisateurs
qui attendent avec impatience le vote du
texte final complétant celui de 2018
ensuite nous devons tirer les
conséquences des événements du Stade de
France du 28 mai dernier qui ont révélé
les risques pesant sur les grands
événements sportifs un certain nombre de
à disposition proposition formulée par
la suite par la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale figure dans la version
amendée par les commissions soyons donc
cohérents et efforçons-nous de conserver
le fruit de ses travaux de fonds enfin
et surtout nous considérons que les
dispositifs qui figurent dans le texte
tel qu'il furent amendés et encadrées
par les travaux de commission et
d'excellents travail de nos rapporteurs
ne sont pas contraires à la Constitution
nous estimons que la conciliation entre
les exigences de la protection des
personnes durant les événements sportifs
et la protection des libertés publiques
qui sont chères à nous tous est assuré
la protection des données est suffisante
les différents dispositifs de sécurité
prévues sont encadrées et dans leur
champ et dans leurs usages enfin si les
travaux de nos collègues députés et le
texte définitif adopté
vous devez y avoir un doute sérieux sur
la constitutionnalité le conseil serait
évidemment saisi et je ne doute pas
qu'il dissipera ces difficultés nous
voterons donc contre cette motion quelle
est la ville de la Commission sur cette
exception du recevabilité
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission a donné un avis défavorable à
cette motion tendante à lire
recevabilité en effet il y a
urgence à adopter ces dispositions
opérationnelles qui sont attendus égard
au fait que les JO c'est dans 18 mois et
la Coupe du monde de rugby dans huit
mois donc il y a véritablement une
urgence d'une part d'autre part nous
avons veillé à ce que les dispositions
notamment en matière de sécurisation
avec la vidéoprotection intelligente ou
les caméras augmentaient ou encore les
dispositifs de lutte contre le dopage
avec l'introduction des tests génétiques
respectent le juste équilibre et nous
avons évidemment une interprétation
différente de madame la Présidente
assassine respecte le juste équilibre
entre l'objectif de sécurisation de
l'ordre public et celui de la garantie
des droits de l'homme et des libertés
c'est la raison que nous pensons
notamment sur la vidéoprotection
intelligente que cet équilibre est
assuré par la réécriture du texte après
l'examen par le Conseil d'État et la
CNIL et l'introduction de nombreuses
garanties tout au long de la procédure
de mise en oeuvre du traitement des
algorithmes d'une part que nous avons
par ailleurs accentué avec un rôle plein
et entier de la CNIL tout au long de la
procédure concernant la lutte contre le
dopage considéré que certes il était
important de pouvoir pérenniser les
tests génétiques mais que à cela a été
assorti de nombreuses garanties
notamment qui interdisaient
l'identification des personnes qui
menaient en place des obligations
d'information forte et tout cela sous le
contrôle là aussi du ccn2 donc un avis
défavorable avis du gouvernement
pour les mêmes raisons d'urgence de
nécessité d'équilibre également un avis
défavorable
il y a-t-il des explications de vote sur
cette notion de procédure il n'y en a
pas je mets aux voix qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient elle n'est pas
adoptée
nous avons maintenant à la discussion de
la motion pendant opposé la question
préalable et dans cette motion qui est
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas dessus
au nom du groupe écologie solidarité
territoire qui l'a déposé
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
aurions aimé nous aurions vraiment aimé
légiférer sur le sport c'est
suffisamment rare nous aurions aimé
légiférer pour que les Jeux Olympiques
et par olympique de 2024 se déroule dans
les meilleures conditions qui laissent
un héritage à la hauteur des ambitions
environnementales fixées à l'origine par
exemple nous aurions adoré faire œuvre
de notre rôle le législateur pour vous
accompagner madame la ministre dans
l'organisation d'un événement auquel
nous sommes attachés dont nous
partageons les valeurs celles de
l'olympisme
nous aurions aussi aimé débats
sérieusement de l'impact de cet
événement sur notre tissu de festival et
d'événements culturels nous aurions pu
rassurer les milliers de professionnels
qui voient dans leur saison de festival
menacé par des annonces verticales et
autoritaires prises sans concertation de
tout cela ils n'en sera rien ou très peu
dans ce projet de loi en revanche au
cœur de ce projet de loi se sont glissés
des innovations législatives hasardeuses
qui n'ont rien à y faire par une
manœuvre d'opportunisme législatifs ce
projet de loi s'est éloigné de son
ambition initiale pour se servir des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024
comme d'un laboratoire d'expériences
sécuritaires le public international ou
national devient grâce à ce projet de
loi le cobaye d'une fuite en avant
expérimentale dans la technologie de
surveillance comment en sommes-nous
arrivés là par quel cheminement
politique sommes-nous arrivés à la
conclusion que l'événement sportif
mondial le plus fédérateur ne pourrait
être utilisé sans le déploiement de
technologie d'intelligence artificielle
d'algorithmes de surveillance
oh il y a bien eu un rapport sénatorial
sur ces technologies mais des rapports
du Sénat on en connaît des dizaines qui
n'ont pas eu comme destin d'être
transformés en loi d'exception ou
d'urgence non il y a eu un événement
déclencheur un événement traumatisant il
faut au moins ça pour aboutir à la
réussite d'un bon cavalier législatif
l'événement le connaît le monde entier
le connaît puisqu'il s'est déroulé en
monde de vision devant des centaines de
millions de téléspectateurs le 28 mai
2022 le soir de la finale de la Ligue
des Champions la capacité de la France a
organisé un grand événement sportif
international a été ce soir à la
sérieusement mise en doute
les mensonges mentement et
approximations du ministre de
l'intérieur comme du préfet de police
ont été mises à jour notamment par notre
Haute Assemblée lors de nombreuses
auditions les causes principalement un
enchaînement de défaillances
organisationnelles mais aussi une
mauvaise préparation notamment dans
l'approche du renseignement sur les
supporters anglais qui a été combiné à
une doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
inadapté plusieurs recommandations ont
été établies par notre rapport
sénatorial sur cet épisode fâcheux
parmi elles peu ont réellement retenu
l'intérêt du ministère intérieur ou du
ministère des sports mais parmi elles il
y en a une qui a été reprise avec une
certaine gourmandise quand elle restait
pour l'instant bloquée par son aspect
sulfureux celle qui consiste à adapter
en urgence mais de façon totalement
expérimentale notre cadre législatif
pour mettre en oeuvre des traitements
d'image par intelligence artificielle
rappelons d'abord que dans notre rapport
sur le Stade de France cette technologie
ne devait concerner que le comptage et
la détection des mouvements de foule
mais déjà au moment du rendu du rapport
des rendus des conclusions de ce rapport
j'avais soufflé les dangers à utiliser
nos grands événements sportifs comme des
showrooms sécuritaires alors disons-le
il y avait déjà un caractère saugrenu
avoir émergé cette recommandation dans
ce rapport
mais une intelligence artificielle
aurait-elle permis d'éviter la
défaillance dans l'orientation des
supporters anglais une intelligence
artificielle aurait-elle déconseillé
l'usage immodéré des gaz l'écritogène
sur des super supporters pacifiques
l'intelligence artificielle aurait-elle
tirée les conclusions en amont d'une
grève touchant l'une des deux lignes de
RER qui menaient au Stade de France en
d'autres termes une intelligence
artificielle aurait-elle fait mieux que
l'intelligence combinée du ministre
Darmanin et du préfet allemand aussi
surprenant que ça puisse paraître je ne
pense pas quand on parle l'intelligence
artificielle pour la vidéo surveillance
il convient de bien comprendre de quelle
technologie nous parlons et du gros du
grand saut dans la société de
surveillance qu'elles nous font faire
les technologies de vidéos dites
augmentées
désigne des dispositifs vidéo auxquels
sont associées des traitements
algorithmiques permettant la une analyse
automatique c'est ce caractère
automatique et en temps réel qui nous
fait changer de monde la CNIL dit dans
son positionnement plus que prudent sur
ces technologies qu'elles sont deux
types d'affecter les garanties
fondamentales apportées aux citoyens
pour l'exercice des libertés publiques
et qu'il est donc nécessaire de changer
la loi changer la loi pas expérimenter
une nouvelle technologie au mépris de
nos libertés publiques non nos libertés
publiques ne sont pas sujet à une
approche expérimentale non nos libertés
publiques n'ont pas être le terrain de
jeu des start-ups de la sécurité non nos
libertés publiques comme nos données ne
doivent pas être marchandées à la légère
avec des apprentis sorciers sécuritaires
oui nous avons besoin d'un débat
approfondie éclairé sur ce changement
radical dans notre approche de l'espace
public il a d'ailleurs déjà lieu au
niveau européen mais n'a toujours pas
abouti
le fait même d'expérimenter cette
technologie est une menace pour nos
libertés publiques pour notre
organisation sociale et pour nos débats
démocratiques certes la promesse de
cette technologie est simple elle
permettrait la détection de situation
permettant de présumer la commission
d'infraction ou encore d'événements
suspects ou potentiellement dangereux
pour cela elle traite en temps réel des
milliers d'images de vidéosurveillance
par traité il faut comprendre il faut
comprendre les confrontés avec un
certain nombre de critères préétablis
pour que ce traitement soit pertinent
l'algorithme a besoin d'apprendre
apprendre pour un algorithme
d'intelligence artificielle c'est se
nourrir de millions d'images de millions
de situations différentes de codifier
compartimenter notre espace public et la
façon dont on l'occupe pour en
distinguer les situations perçues comme
des viandes à risque ou menaçante on
commence là à percevoir ce que ça
implique on commence ici à voir comment
on bascule dans la société de
surveillance celle où le citoyen ce
suspecte lui-même de comportement
inadaptés puisqu'il n'a connaissance
d'un système de surveillance de son
comportement sans en les règles qui ne
sont pas par essence transparentes on va
confier à des sociétés privées la
codification l'organisation de notre
espace public commun ce qui est normal
ou anormal avec tous les biens que ça
implique évidemment il est donc facile
de comprendre l'aubaine que les grands
événements sportifs comme les JO offrent
à ces sociétés c'est les JO deviennent
l'occasion rêvée de nourrir la bête
l'enjeu réel et là il n'est pas dans
l'assistance supposée de ces outils au
moment de l'événement madame la ministre
il est dans l'incroyable masse de
données que les startups qui auront
décroché le marché pourront collecter
lors de l'événement et ne vous faites
pas d'illusions sur les garde-fous qui
ont été introduits dans cette loi
l'ensemble des données sont utiles à
l'algorithme penser qu'il sera possible
d'effacer les données non pertinentes
n'a pas de sens quand on parle
d'apprentissage machine les moments
durant lequel il se passe rien sont tout
aussi utiles que les moments où se
déroulent les événements problématiques
ne serait-ce que pour apprendre à la
machine à les distinguer
l'expérimentation qui est proposée ici
une offre donc aucune garantie sur les
droits et libertés personnes pour
plusieurs raisons mais d'abord parce que
ces algorithmes de son ni contrôlables
ni transparents aussi nous aurons beau
demander dans ce texte que le traitement
des données soit je cite loyal objectif
et de nature et identifier et prévenir
l'occurrence des biais et d'erreurs nous
donnerons aucune garantie c'est toute la
problématique de légiférer sur des
phases algorithmes fermées et au Pâques
le ministre de l'intérieur c'est montrer
très respectueux du cadre législatif
puisqu'ils s'est engagé à ne pas
utiliser de technologie qui n'aurait pas
été légalisées auparavant alors oui ça
paraît logique mais le ministre a tout
de même tenu à nous le préciser lors de
son audition ici le 22 mars 2022 et si
la tenue elle préciser c'est aussi parce
que de son aveu même ce jour-là un
certain nombre de municipalités et
avaient déjà recours à ces technologies
oui le ministre de l'Intérieur celui qui
nous demande aujourd'hui de déployer et
d'encadrer ces technologies dans un
cadre de confiance c'est montrer
incapable de faire respecter la loi qui
entame en cadre déjà triste strictement
ces technologies et tout en ayant
visiblement connaissance d'usage
illégaux de technologie surveillance
n'agit pas pour faire respecter nos
libertés
quelle garantie avons-nous que toutes
les données collectées lors des Jeux ne
serviront pas à nourrir des algorithmes
de surveillance vendus par les sociétés
qui les patrons pendant les jeux à des
régimes moins précautionneux en matière
de liberté publique acceptez-vous chers
collègues que la grande fête des Jeux
Olympiques ça va nourrir les équipements
de répression des mouvements de révolte
contre les tyrannies à l'autre bout du
monde
chers collègues comme vous je suis
attaché au bon déroulement des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
comme vous je souhaite que la centaine
de milliers de spectateurs passent un
moment extraordinaire à vibrer à
l'unisson des valeurs de l'olympisme
mais nous devons nous garder de toute
opportunisme sécurité les Jeux
Olympiques ne doivent pas nous laisser
la société de surveillance globale en
héritage c'est pourquoi je vous propose
de rejeter ce texte afin que la ministre
des Sports puisse exurger les
dispositions qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'événement et que nous puissions
revenir rapidement à une réelle
discussion sur les enjeux réels de
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Didier Rambaud vous avez la
parole contre la motion
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteur mes
chers collègues les arguments contenus
dans la motion que vous présentez chers
collègues Thomas docius soit à mon sens
tout à fait contestable et je
m'efforcerai donc de le démontrer point
par point premièrement vous contestez
l'expérimentation pourtant sur
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle vous considérez que la
création d'un cadre juridique nouveau
autorisant l'usage de l'intelligence
artificielle pour le traitement d'image
de vidéosurveillance traduirait une
volonté indéniable du gouvernement de
pérenniser ses expérimentations au motif
que cela ne s'appliquerait pas
uniquement sur les sites olympiques et
pour une durée dépassant largement celle
des jeux permettez-moi de rappeler que
le dispositif envisagé qui s'inspire de
celui prévu par la proposition de
règlement européen sur des systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle en cours
d'élaboration est assorti de nombreuses
garanties
de la temporalité la proposition du
gouvernement d'expérimenter le
dispositif jusqu'au 30 juin 2025 ne
cache aucune volonté de pérennisation
d'abord les traitements en question
n'utiliseront aucun système dit-on
d'identification biométrique il le
traiteront aucune donnée biométrique et
ne mettront en œuvre aucune technique de
reconnaissance faciale ensuite la CNIL
devrait être régulièrement informé des
conditions de mise en oeuvre de
l'expérimentation qui fera l'objet d'une
évaluation au plus tard six mois avant
son terme qui est fixé aux 30 juin 2025
par conséquent si la durée de
l'expérimentation excède la date de fin
des jeux de Paris à savoir le 8
septembre 2024 rien ne permet d'affirmer
à ce jour que les dispositifs seront
reconduits et encore moins sous quelle
modalités s'agissant des lieux
concernés par l'expérimentation il
semble justifier que le périmètre ne se
limite pas au seul site olympique vu
l'ampleur de l'événement et le nombre de
visiteurs envisagés sécurisé sécurisé
des jeux n'a rien d'évident le
dispositif concernerait les abords
immédiats ce qui inclut notamment le
périmètre des sites d'interconnexion où
les agents des services internes de
sécurité de la SNCF et de la RATP
affecté au centre de la préfecture de
police de Paris pourrait intervenir
ponctuellement le Conseil d'État la
souligné l'expérimentation est destinée
à rendre plus efficace le maintien de
l'ordre pour un événement d'une telle
ampleur et elle sera bel et bien limitée
dans le temps et dans l'espace
deuxièmement vous évoquez un
renforcement injustifié des
interdictions de stade et des sanctions
en cas de pénétration sur une enceinte
sportive qui viserait tout
particulièrement les militants
écologistes chers Thomas docius
rassurez-vous aucune mesure contenue
dans ce projet de loi ne vise les
militants écologistes vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que le 28 mai 2022 date de
la finale de la Ligue des champions des
incidences sont produits au Stade de
France notamment parce que des personnes
ont pénétré ou tenter de pénétrer le
stade par force ou par fraude les
articles créant les deux nouveaux délits
vise justement à sanctionner ces
personnes qui s'introduisent dans une
enceinte sportive sans détenir de
billets d'entrée à ce jour l'entrée dans
une enceinte sportive ne peut faire
l'objet d'une incrimination que
lorsqu'elle est commise en état
d'ivresse ou en situation avérée de
fraude ou d'usage de la force en état
d'ivresse une telle situation juridique
ne peut rester en état et nous devons
renforcer la dissuasion afin d'éviter ce
type d'incident nuisible pour le public
les athlètes et la France en tant que
pays organisateur enfin pour ce qui est
de la pén ou du maintien sans motif
légitime d'une personne sur l'aire de
compétition d'une enceinte sportive je
rappelle que le but recherché et de
sanctionner les personnes qui troublent
à tranquillité de la manifestation
sportive par une amende de 7500 euros
lorsque l'acte est commis en réunion ou
en récidive en dehors de ces deux cas la
sanction sera celle d'une contravention
de 5e classe à savoir une amende de 1500
euros maximum actuellement l'entrée sur
une aire de jeux ne peut être incriminée
que dans deux situations lorsqu'elles
trouble le déroulement de la compétition
ou lorsqu'elle porte atteinte à la
sécurité des personnes ou des biens
encore une fois il s'agit de prévenir
autant que faire ce peu ce jardin qui
troublerait la fête le bien-être des
sportifs et la tranquillité du public
sans occulter le principe de
proportionnalité des peines
troisièmement vous contestez l'extension
de l'usage des scanners à ondes
millimétriques y compris pour des lieux
qui seraient sans lien avec les yeux les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en
réalité l'article 11 du projet de loi
s'inspire de celui applicable aux
aéroports le recours au scanner corporel
est une mesure intrusive c'est vrai
raison pour laquelle le projet de loi
prévoit bien évidemment des garanties
qui répondent aux exigences européennes
à savoir le consentement voire
l'obligation de recueillir ce
consentement express de la personne
contrôlée comme proposé d'ailleurs dans
l'amendement de mon collègue Dominique
Théophile adopté en commission la
possibilité de refus pour accéder à un
autre dispositif de contrôle
l'impossibilité pour l'agent
d'identifier la personne puisque les
images produites par les scanners
correspondent à des représentations
banalisées du corps humain le brouillage
de la
visualisation du du visage
l'interdiction du stockage ou de
l'enregistrement des images autant de
garantie qui permet que nous assurer que
toutes les précautions seront prises
afin d'éviter les dérives alarmantes que
vous craignez tout autant que nous je
vous précise également que cet article
11 permettrait de mettre un terme à une
situation juridiquement alarmante
puisque d'autres portiques de ce type
ont pu être installés par le passé sans
faire l'objet de disposition
législatives autorisant ou encadrant
leur usage cinquièmement vous regrettez
l'autorisation toujours plus élargie de
recours à une publicité visuelle
envahissante qui dénaturent selon vous
les lieux comme les valeurs de
l'olympisme certes on peut regretter
l'omniprésence de la publicité au
quotidien sur les écrans mais considérer
que le fait d'autoriser un peu plus de
publicité pendant une période limitée
pour un événement tel que les jeux en
France ce serait dénaturer les lieux et
dénaturés les valeurs de l'olympisme mes
chers collègues je crois que pas
tantinet radicale je rappelle que seuls
les partenaires de marketing olympiques
au sens du contrat de ville haute pour
en bénéficier des nouvelles dérogations
cela permettra notamment de limiter le
financement public des jeux en attirant
et encore servant des partenaires privés
dans un contexte où la France souhaite
organiser des jeux raisonnables y
compris sur le plan financier ensuite
vous condamnez les dérogations au repos
dominical sur une zone élargie qui
serait sans lien ni justification avec
la nature de l'événement sportif une
fois encore vos craintes sont
injustifiées en effet la mise en oeuvre
de la dérogation au repos dominicale
sera conditionné au respect de
volontariat des salariés ainsi qu'à
l'octroi des contrepartes illégales
prévues dans le code du travail de plus
les communes situées à proximité décide
de compétition ont été intégrés afin
d'éviter un risque de rupture d'égalité
entre les entreprises pour les communes
qui sans être limitrophes aurait pu
avoir une influence de touristes
enfin vous justifiez le dépôt de votre
motion par l'absence de questionnements
ou de mesure portant sur l'héritage des
jeux sur la manière dont les équipements
sportifs seront rendus accessibles à la
population et sur comment les jeux
pourraient redynamiser nos politiques
sportives chers collègues je vous
informe qu'un plan héritage est
durabilité des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 a été
présenté en juin 2022 je vous invite à
le lire car il témoigne du travail mené
qui est considérable et inédit en la
matière un travail qui se poursuivra
afin de répondre aux ambitions
clairement définies sur le plan
environnemental et social Tony estanguay
le dit très bien le nouveau modèle que
nous construisons ensemble ce sont des
jeux qui maîtrisent leur impact sur le
territoire et sur la planète des jeux
inclusifs et fédérateurs des jeux sobre
et durables en conclusion mes chers
collègues
super vous avoir convaincu que la copie
du gouvernement n'a rien de néo-libéral
ou de techno sécuritaires les mesures du
projet de loi sont justifiées et
proportionnés contenu de l'ampleur de
l'événement parce que sécurité et
liberté ne doivent pas être opposées et
parce que les valeurs de l'Olympique
d'être préservé je voterai contre cette
votre motion et vous invite chers
collègues à faire de même
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cette question préalable
madame la Présidente pendant la ministre
mes chers collègues la vie de la
commission était un avis défavorable et
cela pour trois raisons la première
c'est que ce texte est attendu et
nécessaire il introduit des mesures qui
doivent entrer en vigueur le plus
rapidement possible pour être à l'heure
du rendez-vous des Jeux olympiques de
2024 c'est la première raison la
deuxième raison c'est que ces jeux c'est
un engagement de la France c'est un
enjeu pour nous tous et il est normal
que le débat puisse avoir lieu ici au
sein de la représentation nationale
d'autant et c'est la troisième raison
que cela suscite à sa tante de questions
dans l'équilibre on a eu l'occasion de
le dire entre l'objectif de sécurisation
et celui des garanties des droits et des
libertés et qu'il convient d'avoir un
débat démocratique donc ces raisons pour
lesquelles nous sommes défavorables à
cette notion qui tente à écourter le
débat et nous souhaitons qu'il ait lieu
ici au sein de cet assemblée
gouvernement même à vie
même
avis pour les raisons précisément
exposées par le sénateur Didier Rambaud
que saluait également par la rapporteur
je vous remercie merci je consulte le
Sénat qui est pour cette question
préalable qui est contre qui s'abstient
elle n'est pas adoptée nous passons donc
maintenant la discussion générale dans
laquelle la parole est d'abord à
Monsieur Marc Philippe de Brest pour le
groupe les républicains et pour 7
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission des lois mes chers
collègues et amis rapporteur
on vient de le voir parmi les 19
articles de ce projet de loi 3 enjeux se
détache particulièrement la santé la
lutte contre le dopage mais surtout la
sécurité le défi est de taille c'est un
événement d'une ampleur sans précédent
pour notre pays et notre rapporteur la
souligné tout à l'heure la manière dont
le comité olympique a voulu préparer
cette organisation et le pari un peu fou
avec cette idée ambitieuse qui a vu le
jour organisé une parade sur des
embarcations qui parcouront total 6 km
sur scène d'est en ouest pour aboutir
place du Trocadéro ou se terminera la
cérémonie ce Paris induit un défi
garantir la sécurisation de cette
cérémonie en plein air qui pourrait
réunir on l'a dit jusqu'à 600 000
spectateurs
c'est bien le nœud du débat on vient de
l'entendre à l'instant pour rappel
jusqu'à 45 000 forces de l'ordre pour
être mobilisées notre responsabilité
donc de leur donner tous les moyens pour
lutter efficacement contre cette menace
terroriste dans le respect des libertés
publiques les articles 6 à 13 et
notamment l'article 7 du projet de loi
développe les outils nécessaires sur ce
sujet qui a l'évidence nécessite des
moyens exceptionnels cet article prévoit
on l'a dit une innovation majeure pour
le dispositif du maintien de l'ordre
assisté par intelligence artificielle et
il introduit dans le droit la
possibilité d'avoir recours de manière
expérimentale à ce qu'on qualifie de
vidéosurveillance intelligentes ou
augmentée qui utilisent des algorithmes
qui n'ont rien d'opaque afin
d'identifier des situations
potentiellement dangereuses comme des
mouvements de fou l'objectif étant de
gagner des précieuses minutes pour
intervenir avant qu'un drame ne se
produise je tiens affirmer tout le
soutien de mon groupe à ce nouveau moyen
mis à disposition de nos forces de
sécurité qui a obtenu l'aval de la CNIL
du Conseil d'État
saluer le ministère de l'Intérieur et
ses services mais surtout saluer le
remarquable travail de notre rapporteur
Agnès canaillé qui assure renforcer les
garanties apportées pour atteindre ce
bon équilibre en précisant bien son
contenu en commission nous soutenons
également le réécriture par notre
rapporteur de l'article 4 en matière de
test génétique là exposé dans le détail
je souhaite que dans le débat puisse
également mieux prendre en compte les
enjeux en matière de transport notamment
avec les propositions de notre collègue
Philippe Tabarro qui devrait se
concrétiser dans une proposition de loi
mais commençons rapporteur de la
pérennisation de la loi cilte sur le
terrorisme pour lutter contre le
terrorisme il est de mon devoir
d'attirer à nouveau l'attention sur le
risque d'attentat qui plane sur cet
événement depuis juillet
d'ici juillet 2024 240 individus
condamnés pour fêter au risque sont
sortis des prisons françaises de la veut
même du procureur national
antiterroriste a une personne sur quatre
risques de récidiver dans les mois qui
viennent et donc avec un événement de
cette on peut avoir de solides crainte
avec mes collègues Arnaud de Bellay et
Jérôme Durand rapporteur d'une mission
d'information sur la reconnaissance
biométrique dans l'espace public
initiative de la commission des lois
nous nous sommes déplacés à Nice et à
Londres Madame le Ministre afin
d'évaluer les innovations réalisées
notamment avant les JO de Londres et
définir dans quelles conditions nous
pourrions développer à titre
exceptionnel un système utilisant la
reconnaissance biométrique en temps réel
et garantissant une protection maximale
tout en écartant évidemment tout risque
de développement d'une société de
surveillance à la chinoise madame la
ministre vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous estimiez qu'il n'était
pas nécessaire de votre point de vue de
recourir à la reconnaissance faciale
pour une
exception évidemment unique et
proportionnée et pour cet événement
exceptionnel permettez-moi de vous dire
j'ai été aussi au gouvernement je mesure
votre responsabilité et qu'après avoir
été rapporté de la loi sécurité globale
de la loi sur la pérennisation des
dispositifs anti-terroriste et
co-rapporteurs de cette mission
d'information dont je viens de parler
qu'après avoir auditionné tous les
acteurs et défenseurs des République
auquel je suis comme vous attaché
qu’après avoir entendu les représentants
du ministère de l'Inter britannique a
évalué le retour d'expérience après les
JO de Londres je suis convaincu pour ma
part du contraire de fait dans cette
mission d'information dont les
conclusions étaient largement adoptées
par notre commission des lois nous avons
formulé 30 propositions
qui se déclinent en trois axes
principaux et notamment en matière de
reconnaissance faciale la définition
collective d'un cadre comprenant des
lignes rouges évidemment pour écarter
tout risque de d'atteinte aux libertés
publiques une méthodologie claire par la
voie expérimentale et un régime exigeant
et indépendant de contrôle renforçant
singulièrement les pouvoirs de la CNIL
bien évidemment nous rejetons en bloc
l'idée selon laquelle l'État pour avoir
recours de manière usuelle ou qu'on
pourrait pérenniser de tels dispositifs
pour contrôler la population notre idéal
français de liberté d'égalité est
évidemment inomique avec les sociétés
asiatiques du Big Brother pour autant
nous reconnaissons l'intérêt d'une telle
technologie si elle est utilisée dans un
cas de proportionné exceptionnel de
manière très encadrée de manière très
évaluée et pour des événements hors du
commun c'est bien dans ce sens que notre
proposition 22 de la dite mission
ouvrait la voix la possibilité
d'expérimenter cette reconnaissance
biométrique pour les besoins du
renseignement pour des événements
exceptionnels comme celui dont nous
parlons elle consiste à créer donc un
sur ruediquex expérimental permettant
par exception de manière strictement
subsidiaire le recours ciblé et limité
dans le temps des systèmes de
reconnaissance biométrique sur la voie
publique en temps réel sur la base d'une
menace préalablement identifiée à des
fins de sécurisation de grands
événements avec un caractère je l'ai dis
strictement subsidiaire un déploiement
du dispositif autorisé a priori et
contrôlée a posteriori par une autorité
dont nous proposons qu'elle soit la CNIL
un nombre de caméras proportionné une
minimisation des données utilisées et
leur sécurisation une supervision
humaine systématique une traçabilité des
usages et bien d'autres garanties que je
ne vais pas développer ici ce n'est pas
des tours d'un simple amendement à ce
projet dont l'écriture doit être
techniquement affûtée pour rester dans
le cas de constitutionnel respecter les
prescriptions de la CNIL et des
instances européennes que nous pourrons
développer un véritable débat sera et
argumenté je l'avais dit au ministre de
l'intérêt général Darmanin se débat
aurait plutôt dû avoir lieu dans le
cadre de la loi locmi qui nous aurait
permis d'avoir toutes les et à vie
nécessaire je vous annonce donc que je
déposerai une proposition de loi sur ce
sujet avec mon collègue Arnaud de beldé
et en accord avec le président de la
commission des lois qui l'a souhaité
bien évidemment avec les garanties que
nous devons y apporter nous aurons ainsi
l'occasion de pouvoir additionner les
principaux acteurs et des laborer un
dispositif juste et équilibré je
rappelle d'ailleurs que le président du
Sénat à l'occasion d'une proposition de
loi depuis 15 ans peut saisir le Conseil
d'État et je rappelle par ailleurs il
l'a déjà fait que le président de la
commission des lois peut saisir s'il
estime nécessaire la CNIL sur des sujets
de cette importance voilà mes chers
collègues que le souhaitez vous dire
au moment des attentats du Bataclan et
je vous le dis avec une certaine
tonalité j'étais mère
j'ai dû annoncer l'assassiner par des
terroristes à ses parents d'un jeune
homme de 27 ans au Bataclan je ne
souhaite plus jamais revenir ça j'en
mémoire les attentats contre Charlie
Hebdo j'ai en mémoire l'intervention
bouleversée et bouleversante de
Dominique Estrosi Sassone après la
promenade des anglais c'est pourquoi
j'ai confiance en la sagesse du Sénat
pour nous aider à mettre en place un tel
dispositif et apporter toutes les
garanties nécessaires comme je viens de
vous l'indiquer je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre de
colle pour le groupe les indépendants et
pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente
nous entrons aujourd'hui dans la
dernière ligne droite selon Charles de
Montesquieu les dessins qui ont besoin
beaucoup de temps pour être exécuté de
réussite presque jamais bien au
contraire à 18 mois seulement du début
des Jeux nous sommes donc dans
d'excellentes dispositions pour faire de
ces Jeux olympiques et paralympiques une
belle réussite au-delà de la boutade je
salue votre engagement madame la
ministre car vous ne mélangez ménagez
pas vos efforts pour préparer ce grand
événement
ce projet de loi prévoit de nombreux
ajustements visant notamment accorder
notre droit national au contrat conclu
avec le CIO pour accueillir les Jeux en
France
nous attendons collectivement cette
échéance avec un patient
ce texte apporte tout d'abord des
mesures concrètes et novatrices en
matière de lutte contre le dopage on ne
peut que s'en féliciter malheureusement
les auteurs de pratique dopante ont bien
souvent une longueur d'avance sur le
législateur ce texte autorise notamment
les textes génétiques la période qui
suivra la fin des jeux permettra de
tirer tous les enseignements de cette
pratique nouvelle
je salue tout particulièrement la joie
en commission de disposition visant à
rendre obligatoire la vente de billets
d'accès infalsifiable pour les épreuves
cela était justement l'une des
propositions phares du rapport des
présidents de la commission de la
culture et de la commission des lois
dévoilées en juillet 2022
les débordements à la marge de la
récente manifestation sportive organisée
au Stade de France nous ont démontré
toute la pertinence de cette mesure
madame la ministre cet ajout permettra
et nous l'espérons de sécuriser l'accès
aux jeux et aux zones de billetterie
je souhaite également m'attarder sur les
Jeux paralympiques ces épreuves vont
bien au-delà du sport et de la
performance individuelle tant elle
véhicule des valeurs essentielles
d'inclusion et de partage
la pratique de handisport ou aux autres
donne confiance en soi permet aussi de
retrouver une certaine autonomie nous
devons veiller collectivement alors
donner la plus grande visibilité
possible et célébrée fièrement les
quelques 4400 sportifs athlètes qui
s'affronteront à partir du 28 août je
salue à ce titre l'implication sans fil
de la Fédération Française Handisport
des clubs et associations sportives
les Jeux Olympiques représentent aussi
un formidable défi sécuritaire les
grands rassemblements de personnes sont
particulièrement menacés par le
terrorisme nos services de sécurité sont
mobilisés pour faire face à cette menace
nous nous félicitons que ce projet de
loi renforce leur efficacité notamment à
travers la généralisation du criblage
qui resserre les mailles du filet
assurent une plus grande sécurité à nos
concitoyens il existe en outre des
risques inhérents à ces grands
rassemblements de personnes les
mouvements de foule peuvent se révéler
particulièrement dangereux pour les
prévenir le projet de loi autorise la
mise en oeuvre de technologie novatrices
afin de détecter les 6 avant-coureurs de
telle catastrophes nous saluons aussi la
grande implication de la CNIL dans le
développement de ces outils celle-ci
augmente encore les garanties apportées
par ce texte en matière de données à
caractère personnel pour conclure ce
texte et les ajustements apportés par le
Parlement
assureront le bon déroulement de cette
manifestation sportive d'ampleur nous
devons tenir le sprint de finale pour
offrir une se célébration des valeurs du
sport à nos concitoyens et aux quatre
milliards de personnes qui suivent vont
être patients les jeux aux quatre coins
du globe je m'en remets désormais à les
célèbres devises Olympiques qui a déjà
été cité partiellement situé saltuces
communautaire c'est dire plus vite plus
haut plus fort mais ensemble
espérons qu'elle guide les athlètes de
l'équipe de France dans ces derniers
mois d'intense préparation physique et
mental je vous remercie
merci
quand ils sont générale toujours la
parole est à Monsieur Guy benaroche
pardon pour 5 minutes pour le groupe
écologistes solidarité et territoire
merci
les rapporteurs chers collègues nous
trois pour étudier un texte dans le but
affiché et d'adapter notre arsenal
juridique du code du sport au code de la
sécurité intérieure afin de garantir une
organisation fluide et sereine des Jeux
olympiques de leur prochain mais cette
loi vue son contenu va bien au-delà mon
collègue Thomas dessus est l'occasion de
le rappeler notre groupe voit dans le
contenu de ce texte une tentative
sécuritaire peut voiler pérenne et
dangereuse dans sa version initiale 11
des 19 mesures créées de nouvelles
dispositions ou modifie des dispositions
existantes de façon pérenne pour une loi
officiellement dédiée à un événement
temporaire cela peut alerter
la disproportion des mesures pour la
sécurité en jeu dans ce texte cache de
réalisateurs aux droits des personnes
qui plus est s'inscrivent bien au-delà
du temps des jeux tout le déploiement de
la vision sécurité à le recours massif
est presque à différencier à la vidéo
surveillance augmentée des mécanismes
algorithmiques dangereux et
potentiellement bien à disposition plus
tard d'autres opérateurs y compris non
nationaux poste de nombreuses questions
mais au-delà de ce point lié à
l'ambition du surveillance des mesures
plusieurs éléments du texte au service
de l'organisation de ces jeux nous
paraissent problématiques et certains ne
sont pas abordées malgré l'ambition
sécurité de ce texte seul l'aspect
technologique de surveillance de masse
semble le trouver grâce aux yeux de ce
gouvernement peu d'ambition par exemple
dans la lutte contre les cybersattaques
les auditions et les inquiétudes du
terrain on met en avant les carences
liées au recours à des prestataires
privés pour des événements olympiques
mais pas seulement les collectivités
sont inquiète et rien dans ce texte de
son pouvoir les rassurer la vie les
autres activités sportive et culturelle
continueront pendant ces jeux la
sécurisation de ces autres événements
outre un surcoût malvenus pour leurs
organisateurs peuvent souffrir de risque
de précipitation et de formation est
suffisante se pose aussi la question du
report de la charge sur de nombreuses
conditions municipales les fans des
villes hautes entre que Paris
seront-elles sécurisées par la police
nationale pour les festivals et le mode
de la culture le surcoût engendré et
particulièrement important les
formations à minima en raison des délais
mais surtout cette orientation massive
déjà de vers ces formations pour
répondre à un besoin temporaire ne
s'inscrit pas dans la durée
qu'aviendra-t-il une fois les
compétitions terminées une vision
manifestement très courtes de l'héritage
en termes d'emploi en tout cas
ces formations seront retenir les leçons
du fiasco du Stade de France même si je
sais qu'il est dur de tirer les leçons
madame labidyllis d'une situation qui
selon le gouvernement a été bien géré il
est beau aussi de prendre le temps de
rappeler que la cour des côtes avait dès
2018 sous lié les manquements
déontologiques liés au Conseil national
des activités privées de sécurité
l'emploi le droit du travail de son pas
clairement au cœur de la réflexion de ce
projet de loi prenant la modification
injustifiée des règles d'ouverture
d'obédicales sous couvert de
temporalités courtes de volonté de
bénéficier d'un pic de consommation le
gouvernement ouvre la porte à de
nouvelles possibilités de dérogation au
droit du travail le recours au bénévolat
lui aussi est très problématique tout
autant que le recours au secteur privé
ou la concentration de moyens de force
de sécurité nationale et il pose
également la question du respect du
droit du travail la cour des côtes
estime qu'il faudrait employer 22 villes
à 33 000 agents de sécurité privée par
jour pour véritablement sécurisé
l'ensemble des épreuves ces chiffres
dépassent largement les capacités
disponibles dans les entreprises de la
région et du pays la question de la
formation et de recrutement de ces
agents nécessaires n'a pas été anticipé
le spectre de l'expérience Lanaudière et
de l'explosion des coups des pastis si
éloigné cela nous amène également au
triste héritage financier budgétaire que
décide ce texte le dernier rapport de la
cour des côtes alerte clairement sur un
budget qui n'est toujours pas connu et
qui dans les termes de la cour des côtes
n'est pas précisément établi les causes
écosses sont tout aussi accoudu sur les
finances publiques locales
particulièrement en cas de perturbations
à ce jour il existe aucun chiffre réel
et aucune prévision apportée aux villes
si la billetterie veut l'état baisser
pour cause d'épidémie par exemple
l'héritage de ces JO sortent des
préoccupations affichées du comité
d'organisation n'est pas plus
environnementale malgré les annonces et
les efforts locaux à Marseille par
exemple sans le travail de la ville
l'ambition et les actions pour la
préservation et la reconstitution de
l'écosystème marin au bord de mer
n'aurait pas été les mêmes voilà chers
collègues nous trouvons ce texte à
l'image des tentatives de ces dernières
années diriger la surveillance de masse
comme clé de sécurité de justifier les
redancesment aux libertés individuelles
et collective par des arguments
sécuritaires cette vision surtout
lorsqu'elle tente de s'habiller des
habits consensuels de bon déroulement
des Jeux Olympiques et toutes farces
tout comme le titre de cette loi que
nous proposons de changer nous ne sommes
pas dupe et nous proposerons de
recentrer la loi sur ce qu'elle devrait
être l'encadrement des JO et non sur ce
qu'elle est une dérive sécurité pérenne
au détriment des droits de citoyens
aussi faute de modification
significative particulière avant sur la
temporalité d'application des mesures
prévues dans le texte notre groupe
votera ce projet de loi
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Dominique Théophile pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique progressistes
et indépendant et pour six minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
comme Monsieur Madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues dans quelques mois la
France accueillera pour la première fois
depuis un siècle les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques d'été du 24 juillet au 8
septembre prochain
14850 athlètes réparties dans 388
délégations et 58 sports s'affront dans
le cadre de 870 épreuves plus de 11
millions de spectateurs venus du monde
entier sont attendus sur les différents
sites de compétition et à leurs abords
ils seront 4 milliards derrière leur
écran c'est une compétition populaire
aux enjeux inédits la France doit être
au rendez-vous de ces jeux et c'est là
tout l'objectif de ce texte le projet de
loi relatif aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 doit ainsi
permettre à notre pays de répondre de la
manière la plus adéquate possible au
pose l'organisation de tel événement il
vise ainsi à répondre à de nombreux
besoins en matière de sécurité de
couverture sanitaire de lutte contre le
dopage de formation aux gestes qui
sauvent ou de mobilité inclusive ce
texte s'inscrit bien sûr dans le
prolongement de la loi du 26 mars 2018
relative à l'organisation des Jeux et
sur laquelle tout juste élu sénateur
j'avais eu l'occasion d'intervenir il
doit être examiné au regard de la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur que nous avons
adopté le 14 décembre dernier et qui
prévoit de moyens exceptionnels en
matière de sécurité des différents sites
le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui par un chef ce cadre
législatif les sources de satisfaction
sont nombreuses ainsi la mise en oeuvre
de certaines mesures a commencé par
l'ouverture le dimanche des commerces
situés à proximité des sites de
compétition devraient permettre aux
acteurs économiques de profiter de RET
considérable et constitué un véritable
accélérateur d'investissement d'autres
contribueront à limiter le financement
public ce sera le cas notamment de
l'article 14 de l'extension de la
dérogation légale aux interdictions de
publicité dans l'espace public nous
constatons également avec satisfaction
que les dispositifs dérogatoires et
expérimentaux ont été assortis de
nombreuses garanties nous nous
réjouissons en particulier que la ligne
rouge que représente la reconnaissance
faciale n'est pas été franchie ce projet
de loi nous donne par ailleurs
l'occasion de mettre notre droit en
conformité avec le code mondial
antidopage et le droit européen sur la
protection des données je pense
notamment au test génétique au fait de
lutte contre le dopage à l'article 4 et
le cadre légal de la vidéoprotection à
l'article 6 autre motif de satisfaction
certaines dispositions contenues dans ce
texte ont un caractère permanent
le cas de celles prévoyant
l'introduction de deux nouveaux délits
dans le code du sport et qui permettra
de lutter plus efficacement contre les
infractions commises lors de compétition
sportive nous nous félicitons en fin de
constater que certaines mesures
entreront en vigueur dès le lendemain de
la publication de la loi au journal
officielle le rap le laboratoire
antidopage français la SNCF la RATP et
les organisateurs disposeront ainsi du
temps nécessaire pour tester et adapter
les nouveaux dispositifs que sont les
analyses génétiques les caméras
augmentaient ou l'application de la
procédure de criblage ou fanzone et aux
participants aux grands événements la
commission des lois adoptée une
trentaine d'amendements qui sont de
nature à consolider ce texte le
renforcement des garanties entourant
l'expérimentation des traitements
algorithmiques la dernière analyse
automatisée des images de
vidéosurveillance est ainsi bienvenue
il va dans le sens des recommandations
formulées par le Conseil d'État et la
CNIL en ce qui concerne l'encadrement
des tests génétiques au fait de lutte
contre le dopage la rapporteur canaillé
propose d'inscrire l'ensemble du
dispositif dans le code du sport nous
voyons
bien évidemment pas d'inconvénients cela
permettra une mise en conformité de
notre doigt avec le code mondial
antidopage permettez-moi par ailleurs de
me réjouir de l'adoption de l'amendement
que j'ai porté inscrivant l'obligation
de recueillir le consentement
consentement express des personnes
contrôlées au moyen d'un scanner
corporel citons en fin d'extension et
l'adoption d'adaptation par ordonnance
des dispositions de la loi dans les
territoires ultramarins et l'extension
dans le texte de la commission à la
Polynésie française de certaines mesures
d'enquête relatives à la lutte contre le
dopage mes chers collègues ce projet de
loi est un texte nécessaire c'est un
texte que nous avons souhaité équilibré
je vous invite en conséquence à
l'adopter pour faire des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de 2024 une réussite
française un succès pour le monde
sportif et pour nous athlètes et la
grande fête populaire qu'il doit être
je vous remercie de votre attention
je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant Monsieur Jérôme Durand
pour 5 minutes pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et Messieurs le rapporteur nous
sommes réunis ce jour pour l'examen d'un
projet de loi dans le changement de nom
en commission traduit bien la nature
hybride
les sénateurs et sénatrice socialistes
débutent cet examen avec en tête un
objectif la réussite des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de Paris la victoire de
Paris dans le processus d'attribution
des JO 2024 a permis d'effacer le goût
amer de la défaite pour la candidature à
ces mêmes JO en 2012 candidature
déposées sous la présidence de François
Hollande victoire décrochée sous la
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron cet
événement dépasse tes clivage à droite
COP à gauche on a considéré qu'il ne
fallait pas politiser les candidatures
pour accueillir les événements sportifs
si vous me permettez cette paraphrase
d'Emmanuel Macron nous sommes donc
spontanément favorables à ce texte car
nous souhaitons la réussite des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques le groupe
socialiste n'a d'ailleurs pas jugé bon
de déposer des amendements sur un
certain grand nombre de dispositions qui
à notre sentiment ne pose pas problème
mais quelques sujets d'inquiétude
demeurent néanmoins dans ce texte nombre
d'articles prévoient des mesures
destinées à s'inscrire de manière
pérenne dans le droit commun d'autres
visent à mettre en place des
expérimentations et d'autres concerne
bien exclusivement les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques cela me permet de nous
interroger sur l'application de
l'article 45 de la Constitution dans
pareil cas il nous semble bien délicat
de définir précisément le périmètre du
texte je remercie la commission des lois
de nous avoir donné une victoire
symbolique en rebaptisant ce texte comme
portant diverses autres dispositions je
regrette cependant que parmi ces
diverses autres dispositions ne figurent
ni le montant de la taxe de séjour
pendant les Jeux Olympiques ni la
privatisation du réseau de bus parisien
la situation catastrophique des
transports en commun franciliens peu
perdurer jusqu'en 2024 la privatisation
va-t-elle empirer les choses
j'ouvre les guillemets je ne vous ferai
pas croire que nous n'y pensons pas
oserais-je en paraphrasant le ministre
des Transports Clément Beaune hélas nous
ne pourrons pas nous proposencer sur
cette situation dans cette hémicycle
puisque les amendements du groupe
socialiste sur ce sujet qui a pourtant
tout avoir avec l'objet de ce projet de
loi ont été considérés comme ils
recevables ensuite ce projet de loi qui
ne parle pas que des JO tout en parlant
sans ne parlait que de ça ce projet de
loi permet nombre d'expérimentations
notre premier souci est que des
garanties suffisantes soient apportées
pour maîtriser les dérogations dans leur
périmètre leur durée et leur objet et
pour faire en sorte qu'elle soit
parfaitement cadrée le Conseil d'État
avait proposé au gouvernement un
vade-mecum de l'expérimentation en effet
il est bien rare que les
expérimentations ne soient pas
généralisées et c'est à dire qu'elles
sont toutes extrêmement efficaces et
convaincante il est permis d'en douter
le Conseil d'État a donc recommandé au
gouvernement de définir en AM deux
expérimentations des critères de
réussite des objectifs clairs tout en
associant le plus largement possible le
public concerné après avoir lu l'étude
d'impact de ce projet de loi nous
doutons de la définition de ces quelques
critères madame la ministre serait-elle
par exemple en capacité de dire ce qui
pourrait conclure à la non
généralisation de l'utilisation de la
vidéoprotection automatisée certains
défenseurs des libertés publiques
craignent que à la faveur des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques ne se
produisent une accélération de cette
évolution par crainte du terrorisme dont
les conséquences affecteront le champ de
l'ordre public et l'exercice des
libertés ordinaires il est bien
difficile de leur rétorquer qu'il se
trompe et que les mesures proposées ne
sont que temporaires à travers les
auditions de la commission nous avons eu
la confirmation que beaucoup d'acteurs
se projettent déjà dans une
pérennisation je ne dis pas que cela est
incompréhensible mais ne serait-il pas
plus transparent d'indiquer dès le
départ que la plupart des mesures
proposées
en réalité destiné à durer c'est aussi
une des raisons qui nous ont poussé à
rejeter la reconnaissance faciale nous
considérons que le sujet n'est pas
anodin et mérite un débat une
expérimentation et des garanties
d'encadrement élevées pour rendre le
dispositif acceptable on ne peut pas
introduire dans le droit des
dispositions aussi lourdes par le biais
d'amendement sur un texte qui concerne
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
l'intelligence artificielle et la
reconnaissance faciale sont déjà
présentes dans nos vies la plupart de
nos concitoyens sont même déjà
conscients faut-il donc leur faire
croire que ce sont les JO de Paris qui
rendent l'expérimentation technologique
nécessaire nous devons veiller à ce que
le combat contre le terrorisme bien
légitime ne conduisent à des
restrictions de liberté en matière
d'ordre public il convient aussi de ne
pas favoriser l'extension à toutes les
manifestations sur le territoire
national de nouveaux standards de
sécurité ceux qui s'imposent pour les
Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques enfin
et ce n'est pas anodin notamment pour
nos collectivités territoriales nous
devons tenir compte des coûts pour que
les mesures que nous voterons ne pèsent
pas trop lourdement sur les finances
locales
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Jérôme maquis pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste et ce pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ces Jeux Olympiques
auraient pu auraient dû constituer un
élan exceptionnel en faveur d'une
politique sportive ambitieuse et
populaire le texte sur la
démocratisation du sport voté en début
d'année ni a malheureusement pas répondu
et ce texte n'apportera rien en la
matière pire celui-ci semble servir de
soupapes au gouvernement pour prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions
restaignan restreignant pardon les
libertés individuelles et collectives
appelées à s'appliquer de façon pérenne
ce projet de loi aurait pu être
l'occasion d'un débat positif sur la
méthode à adopter pour que la prochaine
Coupe du monde de rugby où les Jeux
olympiques de Paris constitue un
héritage économique et social vertueux
pour la population au-delà de la
performance de nos athlètes et de la
bonne tenue des Jeux en matière de
Sécurité de Transport ce qui constituera
leur réussite se seront des jeux qui
permettront de casser les barrières
sociales terr ou lié au handicap entre
les usagers et la pratique sportive et
puis comment concevoir un héritage
économique pour nos collectivités en
matière d'équipements alors même
qu'aujourd'hui elles peinent à soutenir
la vie associative ou encore à maintenir
ouvert leurs équipements du fait de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie que l'on
se comprenne bien je suis
résolument pour la tenue de ces Jeux
Olympiques dans notre pays la promotion
fait au sport des leads ne me gênent pas
et les bonnes performances de nos
athlètes nous honorerons ainsi à défaut
d'un héritage social nous devrons nous
satisfaire d'un héritage sécuritaire des
Jeux Olympiques pourtant loin de nous
l'idée de négliger la sécurité de
millions de femmes et d'hommes venus
assister au festivités mais les
dérogations apportées aux droits communs
en matière de droit des justiciables
risquent de saper les lampes populaires
que doit mener cet événement mondial
l'un des objectifs de ce texte est de
légaliser la vidéo surveillance
algorithmique la vidéo surveillance
algorithmique à tout autant recours que
la reconnaissance faciale à l'analyse
biométrique autrement dit à la détection
de corps pour repérer ou identifier une
personne étape par étape la population
est préparée à devoir accepter de
nouvelles technologies sous couvert de
leur caractère exceptionnel et limité
dans le temps alors même que l'on sait
que ce gouvernement présente la fâcheuse
tendance d'inscrire de manière pérenne
des dispositions d'état d'exception dans
le droit commun cette préoccupation
exprimée par l'ensemble des membres de
mon groupe et aussi de la part de la
CNIL de la Ligue des droits de l'homme
ou encore du Conseil d'État je pense
madame la ministre que ces
préoccupations méritent que l'on s'y
planche de plus près en outre ce texte
de loi en plus de n'importe aucune
garantie supplémentaire de bonnes
gestion de l'événement pour les
supporters dans les stades celui-ci
s'inscrit dans une ligne du tout
sécuritaire qui nous semble compte
productif
nous amendements proposent de corriger
cette orientation notamment en matière
de pointage en effet nous pensons qu'il
est nécessaire de rendre proportionné
cette mesure au regard du comportement
de la personne en outre concernant la
pyrotechnie les supporters partout dans
le monde utilisent des torches ou des
fumigènes pour animer les tribunes bien
que ce soit interdit cette pratique
perdure et sa répression des effets
opposés à ce poursuivi puisque celle-ci
conduit les supporters à rendre leur
utilisation encore plus dangereuse par
ailleurs cette gestion sécuritaire des
jeux s'illustre aussi par le recours de
près de 25000 agents de sécurité privée
de l'extension de leur prérogative en
vue des Jeux lorsque l'on sait qu'il
faudrait recruter et former 25000 agents
en 18 mois je cite la probable
insuffisance de la sécurité privée
souligner récemment par la Cour des
Comptes est un doux euphémisme
dans ce contexte de manquer de
ressources humaines dans la filière de
la sécurité privée lors des Jeux nous
serons particulièrement vigilants à ce
que aucune complaisance ne soit faite
concernant notamment le travail
dissimulé ou le recours au travailleur
sans papier faute d'une préparation
sérieuse nous en sommes amené à devoir
faire appel aux réserves de la police de
la gendarmerie et des armée entre les
festivals de musique annulés faute
d'agents de sécurité publique et les
forces amées assurant le maintien de
l'ordre public je peine à distinguer
l'horizon d'une quelconque communion
populaire lors de ces jeux en parlant
des préparations je pourrais aussi
rappeler les promesses de cette exécutif
de répondre aux besoins de mobilité
générés par les jeux et ce de manière
décarbonée qui auront du qui auront du
mal pardon à être tenus avec seulement
le prolongement de la ligne 14 qui sera
livrée à temps il est vraisemblablement
probable que l'acceptabilité des jeux y
soit là encore malmené de par son connu
contenu en matière de disposition
restreignant un certain de liberté
individuelle et collective mais aussi
par ces manquer en matière de politique
sportive et notamment de mesures
concrètes sur l'héritage des jeux nous
ne pourrons pas voter ce texte je vous
remercie merci la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Arnaud de Bennett pour 8
minutes pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
même la présidente mais madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues
dans la dernière ligne droite avant les
JO
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
votre projet de loi ambitionne
d'améliorer leur organisation et la loi
c'est aussi dans la dernière ligne
droite cet automne du troisième
événement le plus médiatisé au monde la
coupe de rugby
que que ce projet de loi
améliore le dispositif
il présente des adaptations nécessaires
en matière d'offre de soins et de
formation au premier secours des moyens
pour renforcer le dispositif de lutte
contre le dopage et divers autres
mesures dont la possibilité pour la
solideo de recourir à l'intervention
d'autres états
il prévoit il renforce surtout la
sécurité des jeux ainsi que des grands
événements que la France accueille le
chapitre 3 au gré des mesures
importantes de sécurité qu'il implique
et du traitement des questions parfois
épineuses méritent une attention
particulière comme l'indiquait
d'ailleurs par ailleurs le rapport
d'information
coécrit avec Marc clip de Brest et
Jérôme Durin en mai 2022 la
reconnaissance biométrique dans l'espace
public 30 propositions pour écarter le
risque d'une société de surveillance j'y
reviendrai quelques imprécisions ou
imperfections dans le texte du projet de
loi ont été relevés notamment le fait
que l'installation de système de
vidéoprotection n'aurait été réalisable
uniquement dans les moyens de transport
et les voiles et des servants je me
félicite que Madame la rapporteur est
repris notre amendement en commission
pour éclaircir le sens de ces termes et
préciser ainsi que l'installation de
système de vidéoprotection sera
convenable dans les gares et les seuls
moyens publics de transport
nous aurions pu ne pas rejeter un
amendement sur l'article 6 du projet de
loi qui visait à maintenir l'obligation
pour le gouvernement de transmettre à la
CNIL un rapport annuel sur l'activité
des commissions départementales de
vidéosprotection il est vrai que ces
rapports ne sont plus rendus à la CNIL
depuis 2013 et que tout cela a assez peu
de conséquences pratiques
mais cela me chagrine de supprimer une
obligation légale qui s'impose au
gouvernement au motif au seul motif que
le gouvernement s'y soustrait depuis des
années
en première année de droit je me
souviens d'avoir appris ou réappris que
le respect de la Constitution le respect
du droit fond de la démocratie
et même si cela n'arrange pas la règle
doit être respectée
il est même possible d'anticiper
il est même possible d'anticiper des
nominations et des mêmes possibilités
des limites d'âge
il pourrait même être organisé des
tuilages avec des adjoints
et c'est pourquoi nous exprimerons une
hostilité à un amendement d'Ancien
Régime très versaillé
mais nous pourrions envisager le cadeau
d'un amendement réécrit plus justifié et
démocratique
à propos de l'article 17 du projet de
loi et de la possibilité de donner aux
commerces à déroger repos dominicales je
salue madame la ministre que vous ayez
retenu la vie du Conseil d'État il
suggéré au nom de l'égalité entre les
entreprises d'étendre le périmètre
géographique de la mesure aux communes
situées à proximité décide de
compétition et non de le restreindre au
seul communes d'implantation de ces
sites et aux communes limitrophes nous
saluons d'une manière générale le
travail de la rapporteur Agnès canailler
qui a permis de trouver un équilibre je
pense notamment à l'article 4 concernant
la lutte contre le dopage qui recourt à
la réalisation d'analyses par des
examens génétiques la solution trouvée
permettre l'expérimentation pour les
tests génétiques les plus intrusifs me
paraît plus raisonnable sur le plan
éthique
de même nous souscrivons aux garanties
apportées par la commission des lois
concernant l'installation de scanner
corporel à 11 mm
garantie basée sur le volontariat à la
fois des gestionnaires et des personnes
contrôlées à qui on ne pourra pas
imposer ce dispositif
nous doutons cependant de la portée
pratique de cette faculté au regard de
la capacité des opérateurs à investir
dans ces machines coûteuses et à
disposer des agents formés nous verrons
bien
enfin si nous reconnaissons l'utilité de
ce projet de loi nous aurions aimé que
ce dernier ne subisse pas lui aussi la
sentence d'une procédure accélérée qui
nuit au temps de dialogue et de débat
nécessaire au bon fonctionnement
démocratique
et c'est justement et aussi parce que ce
texte ne peut par manque de temps faire
l'objet de discussion plus approfondie
que nous saluons la décision du
gouvernement et celle de la commission
des lois de ne recourir à l'intelligence
artificielle qu'à titre expérimental de
manière limitée
limitée dans le temps limité dans
l'espace et dans un cadre très restreint
et particulièrement sans aucune
utilisation de données biométriques
nous avions posé dans le rapport que je
précipitais avec Mark Philippe debrés et
Jérôme Durin une condition de
subsidiarité je crois qu'elle est mise
en œuvre ici
le dispositif de filtrage les billets
sécurisés cher à Laurent Lafont
sont une alternative efficace nous
disent les services de sécurité à des
dispositifs de reconnaissance
biométrique nous avons mis en œuvre les
préconisations du rapport adopté par la
commission des lois dans ce texte tel
qu'il est issu de la Commission et nous
pouvons que nous en féliciter pardon il
protège nos concitoyens à la fois
physiquement lors de l'organisation de
cet événement mais il protège aussi leur
liberté publique
il nous faudra
fixer dans une nouvelle loi
d'expérimentation marque Philippe
devrait se le disait les conditions dans
lesquelles et les finalités pour
lesquelles la reconnaissance biométrique
pourra faire l'objet de nouvelles
expérimentations par les acteurs publics
ou dans les espaces publics
un débat on l'a vu aujourd'hui
à cette tribune
un débat spécifique et nécessaire
il devra apaiser et il aidera
certainement à objectiver
cette loi sera nécessaire avant le
règlement européen
elle sera nécessaire aussi à notre
souveraineté
cette loi elle sera spécifique elle sera
nécessaire et elle sera
urgente face à la réalité des
développements des pratiques
face au cas d'usage qui se développe
chaque jour dans notre pays il nous
faudra un cadre juridique il nous faudra
accepter le principe d'un cadre
juridique
que le seul relatif à la protection des
données ne peut ne peut nous offrir il
faudra que ce cadre juridique pose les
interdits et les préalables
tout cela est absolument nécessaire nous
en avons convenu en commission des lois
mercredi dernier
je mens
réjouis tout particulièrement et je vous
remercie chers collègues de votre
attention
très bien la parole est maintenant
madame Esther Benbassa pour 3 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteur mes
chers collègues je résumé comme
Hemingway prétendre que Paris est une
fête et me réjouir de la tenue des Jeux
Olympiques sur nos territoires j'aurais
aimé faire comme si tout allait bien
comme si l'on pouvait circuler
normalement en Île-de-France comme si
les transports en commun étaient
fonctionnels et sans danger la vérité
que j'ai du mal à imaginer Paris en
plein Jo alors que nous avons déjà tant
de mal à sécuriser un match de foot
rappelez-vous monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre excusez-moi de
l'épisode du fiasco du Stade de France
le 28 mai dernier on peut espérer que le
préfet évitera le pire et assurera mieux
la sécurité
des 13,5 millions de spectateurs
attendus
pour le moment l'enjeu est primordial et
ce texte vise à y faire face en
proposant une série de dispositions qui
pose tout de même de sérieuses questions
eu égard à nos droits et libertés
l'article 7 de cette loi prévoit le
recours aux caméras augmentées utilisant
l'intelligence artificielle aussi
appelée vidéo surveillance algorithmique
VSA visant à détecter des situations
anormales on parle alors d'une
technologie qui analysera classera
évaluera nos moindres faits et gestes
dans l'espace public la Quadrature du
Net une association de défense et de
promotion des droits et libertés sur
Internet dénonce une véritable frénésie
sécuritaire un projet totalement
dystopique
le Conseil d'État dans son avis juge que
ce projet de loi est susceptible de
mettre en cause la protection de la vie
privée et d'autres droits et libertés
fondamentales telles que la liberté
d'aller et venir et les libertés
d'opinion et de manifestations lorsque
ces dernières s'exercent à l'occasion de
ces événements il appelle l'intervention
du législateur pour encadrer le texte de
garantie rigoureuse d'autant plus que
l'homme de mesures de ce texte
concernant la sécurité en vocation à se
pérenniser dans nos droits communs
dépassant le script cadre des Jeux
Olympiques
il faudra être particulièrement attentif
et trouver le juste équilibre en
sécurité protection de nos libertés
n'oublions pas non plus
l'immense coup écologique de cet
événement grand producteur de CO2 on
aurait pu s'en passer je voterai contre
ce texte je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Bernard fiater pour 5 minutes pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social européen
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames Messieurs le rapporteur chers
collègues
tout le monde s'était réjoui de
l'attribution des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à Paris mais depuis
plusieurs événements interrogent sur les
conditions de son organisation que ce
soit les débordements du Stade de France
pour la finale de la Ligue des Champions
ou les conditions de réalisation de la
Coupe du monde de football au Qatar
il faut tout faire pour que le sport
sorte vainqueur de cette compétition et
pas la seule réussite commerciale de cet
événement planétaire le sport propre
dans l'exemplarité des disciplines
exigeantes peut médiatiser avec des
athlètes admirables plutôt que le sport
business et les vecteurs commerciaux que
deviennent désormais certaines stars du
sport
notre pays doit être à la hauteur de ces
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques par la
maîtrise des coûts de l'organisation par
la sécurité due aux athlètes et aux
spectateurs et enfin par l'héritage que
doit léguer cet événement
la Cour des comptes dit ne pas être en
mesure à ce stade d'établir le coût
global des jeux et son impact total sur
les finances publiques les chiffres
avancés pour le budget du kojob et de la
solideo dépasse les 8 milliards d'euros
avec une part de financement public qui
s'établirait après de 2,4 milliards le
coût réel des jeux comprendra aussi les
dépenses des collectivités territoriales
et les dépenses de l'État relative au
dispositif de sécurité autour des jeux
et au sein des infrastructures transport
au sein de la commission culture nous
avons adopté l'amendement de notre
collègue rapporteur Claude Kern
prévoyant que la Cour des comptes
établisse un bilan du coup global des
événements et présente l'héritage des
jeux à travers la réutilisation des
événements et des infrastructures mises
en place
madame la ministre vous avez fait part
de votre objectif que les je laisse une
empreinte durable tout d'abord matériel
notamment en scène Saint-Denis avec la
construction d'équipements sportifs de
proximité de 4000 logements accessibles
ou d'aménagement routiers piétons ou
vélo d'utilité publique nous veillerons
à la réalisation de ces objectifs
auxquels nous adhérons
dans ce sens la commission Culture a
adopter l'amendement de notre président
Laurent Lafont visant à permettre une
mutualisation des moyens de la solideo
avec un autre établissement de l'État
ceci devrait permettre à la société de
se maintenir durant la phase de
reconversion des ouvrages en s'appuyant
sur les moyens d'un autre établissement
public foncier et d'aménagement
autre point l'accueil des jeux crée
aussi des interrogations voire des
inquiétudes sur la manière de répartir
les effectifs chargés du maintien de la
sécurité sur l'ensemble du territoire 30
000 forces de l'ordre seront mobilisées
chaque jour pendant les épreuves et leur
présence dans les transports en commun
sera également doublé
nous regrettons que l'amendement de
notre collègues du groupe RDS ce
Nathalie Delatte n'était retenu il
visait à s'assurer que les personnels
temporairement affectés à des missions
de maintien ou de renforcement de la
sécurité des jeux ce que nous approuvons
retrouve à la fin de l'événement leur
affectation intérieure au plus tard le
31 décembre 2024 en effet lors de la
période des jeux aucune compagnie CRS
maître nageur sauveteur ne sera affecté
sur les plages du fait de leur
mobilisation sur les sites de
l'Olympiques de nombreux élus craignent
les conséquences de cette absence
associée à un flux majeur touriste et il
redoute aussi que l'absence de ses
compagnies de sécurité sur les plages ne
deviennent pérennes
alors j'en viendrai à l'héritage
immatériel que devront laisser ces Jeux
Olympiques et par olympiques au-delà du
rayonnement touristique de la France ils
sont une formidable opportunité de
promotion de la pratique sportive par la
mise en lumière de disciplines encore
confidentielle dans notre pays du
handisport et du sport féminin dont nous
célébrons d'ailleurs aujourd'hui même la
journée internationale et plus
généralement
l'encouragement la pratique sportive
pour tous cette source d'épanouissement
d'apprentissage et de respect des règles
des arbitres des adversaires au temps de
valeur que notre pays a bien besoin de
rappeler
vous savez madame la ministre mon
entêtement a soutenir le sport scolaire
et universitaire qui sont constitutifs
de l'éducation de notre jeunesse en
cette journée d'ailleurs internationale
de l'éducation et qui mérite d'être
reconnu et encouragé bien au-delà de ce
qu'ils connaissent actuellement surtout
en regard de la promotion des Jeux
Olympiques loin de l'élitisme social de
ces origines et du sport business actuel
avec ses athlètes produits ils puisent
dans l'esprit olympique un équilibre
entre la promotion de l'activité
physique et les valeurs de respect et de
fraternité enfin je salue la décision
qui permet à la France Télévisions de
rester diffuseur officiel des Jeux
Olympiques alors où certaines jeudis
certaines rencontres sportives
disparaissent des chaînes du service
public il est bon que tous les Français
puissent regarder les jeux dont ils
contribuent au financement sur la
télévision publique pour ces raisons
nous le groupe RDSE votre en faveur du
texte
presque fini par l'infini Monsieur
Michel ça va pour le européen
républicain et pour 7 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de Paris 2024
contrairement à ce qu'indique leur nom
de ses limitent pas la seule capitale
plusieurs autres vides se sont engagés à
accueillir des compétitions des centres
de préparation les villages des athlètes
et des médias le parcours de la flamme
etc ce sont également toutes les
collectivités de labellisés terre de
jeux tous les établissements scolaires
génération 2024 qui au travers des
actions mises en place partage tous le
double objectif celui de développer la
pratique sportive et celui de faire
rayonner l'Olympus sur l'ensemble du
pays
or à 18 mois du début des compétitions
force et de constater que l'enthousiasme
de la population française reste pour le
moins mesurée les Français devant pour
leur faire face aux cris sanitaires
sociales et celle du pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui il est donc de notre
responsabilité collective que l'État le
Parlement les collectivités et la grande
famille du sport français de tout faire
pour préparer dans les meilleures
conditions l'organisation et l'accueil
de la plus grande compétition sportive
planétaire
pourtant il y a quelques jours la Cour
des comptes dans son dernier rapport de
relever un grand nombre d'incertitudes
un équilibre financier qui n'a pas
encore été trouvé des délais serrés pour
la livraison de toutes les
infrastructures une organisation loin
d'être dans les clous concernant l'offre
de transport qui a ce rythme ne pourra
pas être pris prête à temps et enfin des
questions de sécurité évidentes
auxquelles ce projet de loi et a raison
largement consacré ce texte a donc pour
objectif d'inscrire dans la loi
plusieurs mesures complémentaires de
celles déjà adoptées dans le cadre de la
loi du 26 mars 2018 le Sénat au travers
des amendements déposés par nos
rapporteurs Agnès canailles et Florence
lazarade et Caude Kern mais aussi de nos
collègues précisent et renforcent
certains dispositifs inscrits dans ce
projet de loi je tiens à les remercier
pour la qualité et la pertinence de leur
proposition
reconnaissons que l'essentiel de ce test
va dans le bon sens avec de nouveaux
dispositifs et des Rogations règles
normales ainsi que certaines
expérimentations sur le plan des soins
sur celui de la sécurité qui est encore
renforcé ou encore aux mesures
antidopage qui pérennisent constituent
un héritage durable de ces jeux dont
nous pouvons être fiers
il y avait en effet urgent à adapter des
dispositifs complémentaires en matière
de gestion des grands événements
vidéoprojections contrôle des entrées
renforcement des sanctions pour l'effet
de violence ou de fraude sécurité les
transports le texte veut tout terrain
encore faut-il bien délimiter le
périmètre des mesures exceptionnelles et
celui des changements permanents aussi
nous sommes favorables à ce texte qui je
l'espère nous permettra d'éviter à
nouveau fiasco comme celui du Stade de
France devenu le symbole de tous les
dysfonctionnements possibles lors d'une
rencontre internationale
je suis soulignerai quand même deux
angles morts de ce projet de loi sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas eu la
possibilité d'amander le premier angle
mort qui touche les volontaires
bénévoles
l'absence de garantie sur le recueil qui
révèle des problématiques propres à
l'événement avec des logements peu
accessibles en Île-de-France et Paris
intra-muros ou l'absence de facilité de
transport peuvent créer un sentiment
d'exclusion à l'opposé des valeurs de
l'olympisme
faut-il rappeler que le delà des
chiffres il y a des femmes et des hommes
qui vont consacrer leur temps leur
énergie à faire de ces jeux une réussite
à tous les niveaux il doit pouvoir le
faire dans les meilleures conditions
le dispositif de volontaire les
conditions de candidatures les rôles à
signer à chacun sont inscrits dans la
Charte du volontariat olympique et
paralympique que nous devons à la loi de
pour la grande majorité des bénévoles
c'est un cadre sain clair qui les
protège alors qu'il protège aussi les
spectateurs mais là encore il y a
toujours des doutes qui persistent
quelle est la valeur contraignante d'une
charte pour des profils dangereux qui
souhaiteraient à tout prix gâcher la
fête car en l'état ni l'organisateur ni
le gouvernement n'apporte de réponse
satisfaisante
d'autre part le premier président de la
Cour des comptes souligne la nécessaire
vigilance face au risque juridiques
associés à la charte du volontariat
olympique une requalification en travail
salarié de certaines missions d'une
partie des bénévoles pouvant constituer
une complication juridique et financière
non négligeable
deuxième angle mort la billetterie le
kojob il tient les billets seront
nominatifs or les partenaires comme la
ville de Paris la région Île-de-France
les entreprises associations
via la billetterie sociale se feront les
acquéreurs de place pour inviter du
public à quel nom seront ces billets
comment s'assurer que les personnes se
présentant avec un billet en sont bien
les propriétaires comment assurer ce
contrôle
sa réponse précise à ces questions
pourtant pratiquement pratique tous nos
grands débats seront vains
le billet d'entrée ce n'est pas un objet
ordinaire c'est la clé d'accès
l'expérience olympique pour des millions
de personnes venues du monde entier et
pour et pour beaucoup de jeunes c'est
aussi le sésame vers une première
rencontre avec le sport de haut niveau
alors maintenant madame la ministre
pour ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques l'important ce n'est pas
uniquement de participer mais de
s'assurer de leur succès il faut agir
vite plus haut plus fort et je
rajouterai ensemble merci
merci la parole est enfin monsieur
Jean-Jacques Lauzac pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains et
pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidentes
commissures mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteur mes chers collègues ce
troisième texte relatif à l'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris de 2024 après les textes de 2018
et 2019 a été inscrit l'ordre du jour
dans la continuité de son dépôt au Sénat
le 22 décembre dernier des délais
contraints restreignant le temps de
travail à lui consacrer la réussite déjà
de 2024 événement tout à fait
exceptionnel étonné enjeu majeur vers
lequel nous tendons collectivement
pendant 6 semaines 13 millions de
spectateurs et 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs sont attendus
l'équivalent de 54 championnats du monde
seront organisés simultanément et
circonscrit à un même lieu ou presque
nous notons que globalement le
gouvernement a respecté l'essentiel des
recommandations du Conseil d'État de la
CNIL parallèlement le projet loi
regroupe tout un ensemble de
dispositions pérennes ou amenées à
l'être après expérimentation et ou
évaluation et qui dépasse largement
notre sujet olympique en s'appliquant
potentiellement à des manifestations
récréatives sportives et culturelles
ayant lieu avant et après 2024 coupe du
monde de rugby 2023 concert festival etc
les décrets d'application définissant la
nature des événements concernés où les
seuils retenus seront l'objet de notre
particulière attention c'est en ce point
que réside la dimension post-olympique
du texte absente d'un intitulé réducteur
bien que précisé en Commission
concernant les spéc sécuritaires du
débat il apparaît que les enseignements
suite aux incidents survenus lors de la
finale de la Ligue des champions au
Stade de France le 28 mai dernier était
globalement tiré par les ministères
concernés la digeste la Diop
cependant deux situations sensibles sont
identifiées la cérémonie d'ouverture et
le parcours de la flamme olympique dans
le pays la gestion de la cérémonie
d'ouverture apparaît d'une grande
complexité et nécessite un haut degré
d'anticipation des moyens accrus et un
niveau de technicité auquel nous n'avons
jusqu'à leur jamais recouru des
arbitrages rapides sont nécessaires afin
de susciter la sérénité dans l'opinion
publique ces choix stratégiques
intègrent également la gestion des
risques d'atteinte aux personnes et aux
biens et la politique de la délinquance
du quotidien aux abords des sites
accueillant des compétitions et qui
pourraient menacer le caractère paisible
de l'événement le recours est
mobilisation d'effectifs en grand nombre
publique et privé sera nécessaire le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
n'a pas manqué d'alerter sur l'impact de
ce défi dans le financement sera la
charge exclusive du kojob pour conclure
j'attire votre attention sur la
problématique de la relation entre
l'organisateur et le public uniquement
appréhender dans ce texte à travers le
volet répressif celui de la sanction de
la lourdeur des peines appliquée par
exemple au football certains articles
s'appliquant au match de Ligue 1 et de
Ligue 2 or les autres volets de la
relation club supporters ne sont pas
abordées finalement la réussite des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 reposera en grande
partie sur l'équilibre que nous
parviendrons à trouver entre la quiétude
que nous devons nous habitants
spectateurs et participants tout en
préservant la dimension fédératrice et
festive de l'événement je vous remercie
merci la discussion générale est close
et nous passons donc maintenant à la
discussion du texte de la Commission à
l'article 1er et la parole est un âme
Corinne Ferré
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre l'article premier crée la
polyclinique olympique et paralympique
prévue par le contrat ville haute nous
avons bien compris que la création de
cette polyclinique sous forme de centre
de santé vise à préserver la bulle
sécuritaire que le village olympique et
par olympique pour les athlètes mais
aussi